My name is Brianna and I'm from Naples, Florida.
我叫布里安娜，来自佛罗里达州那不勒斯。
I am Harrison and I'm from the United Kingdom.
我是哈里森，来自英国。
I'm from Brazil and I'm from the Netherlands.
我来自巴西，我来自荷兰。
And I'm from Iowa, from Rhode Island, Connecticut.
我来自艾奥瓦州，来自罗德岛，还有康涅狄格州。
From Dallas, Texas, Florida.
来自德克萨斯州达拉斯，还有佛罗里达州。
I am from Bulgaria, from India.
我来自保加利亚，来自印度。
I'm from Chile and I'm from Spain.
我来自智利，我来自西班牙。
This is Selma from Bosnia and Herzegovina.
我是来自波黑的塞尔玛。
I'm from Australia.
我来自澳大利亚。
Hi, here's Maya from Poland.
嗨，我是来自波兰的玛雅。
I'm Charlotte from England.
我是来自英国的夏洛特。
And Robin Shabatsky is my favorite sexual character of all time.
罗宾·什巴斯基是我有史以来最喜欢的女性角色。
And she's generally my favorite character in television history.
总的来说，她也是我电视史上最喜欢的角色。
Absolutely my favorite character of all time.
绝对是我有史以来最喜欢的角色。
Robin Shrobotsky means everything to me.
罗宾·什罗博茨基对我来说意味着一切。
To me, Robin Shrobotsky means strength and confidence.
对我来说，罗宾·什罗博茨基意味着力量与自信。
Strong, independent and didn't follow the usual expectations of what a woman should be like.
坚强、独立，不墨守成规于女性应有的传统期待。
Both a Canadian cop star and a gun tote in cigars smoke in New Yorker.
既是加拿大流行巨星，又是带枪、抽雪茄的纽约客。
Robbie, me, scourish, she's talent, she's amazing.
罗比，天哪，她太有才了，她太棒了。
She's a percent of strength, coalition and vision.
她是力量、信念与愿景的化身。
Such a badass.
简直酷毙了。
She stays focused on her goals and knows what she wants out of life.
她始终专注于自己的目标，清楚自己想要怎样的人生。
What she means the most is that you can be hilarious and have a heart.
她最珍贵的地方在于，你既可以幽默风趣，又可以充满同理心。
Why love Robin?
为什么要爱罗宾？
Because Robin is Robin.
因为罗宾就是罗宾。
Robin does not need anyone, and she likes having her own space, her own dessert.
罗宾不需要任何人，她喜欢拥有自己的空间和甜点。
Is it strong enough to walk away when it's right for her?
当断则断，有足够的勇气在不合适时抽身离去。
Robin reminds me that I can be vulnerable and strong at the same time, that I can love others but also love myself.
罗宾提醒我，我可以同时做到脆弱与坚强，我既能爱别人也能爱自己。
I love how she can hold her friends accountable, and I can also step aside and let them figure it out for themselves.
我喜欢她能对朋友严格要求，同时也懂得退一步让他们自己去解决问题。
Seeing a woman on TV who wasn't afraid to be different It made me feel like I wasn't alone.
在电视上看到一个不怕与众不同的女性，让我觉得自己并不孤单。
I've gone through some really rough times in my life being autistic, but Robin has been the one trying light that guided me through me.
我作为自闭症患者经历过生活中一些非常艰难的时刻，但罗宾一直是指引我度过难关的那道光。
I would love to take a second to appreciate how curvy small it is.
我想花点时间表达对寇碧·史莫德斯的欣赏。
It's such an incredible actress.
她是一位如此出色的演员。
I also just love curvy small, there's so much.
我也超级喜欢寇碧·史莫德斯，她太棒了。
I met her once, and she said I was an artist.
我曾见过她一次，她说我是一位艺术家。
And I wanted to thank her for saying that, because I really needed to hear it.
我想谢谢她这么说，因为我当时真的很需要听到这句话。
Her ability to make me laugh, smile, or even cry through her amazing accent as well.
她那迷人的口音总能让我开怀大笑、微笑甚至落泪。
And it's one of the biggest constants in my life.
这是我生活中最恒久不变的陪伴之一。
I can meet her and say to you, the former and the most character that made me feel like he already fell down a lot, but don't get out of me.
我可以去见她，然后对她说，这个对我影响最深的角色让我明白即使跌倒很多次，也不要放弃。
I'm alone, I won't be soon.
我并不孤单，也不会孤单太久。
In New York City, when I see you, please permit me to tell you everything in New York City.
在纽约市，当我见到你时，请允许我告诉你关于纽约市的一切。
Hello, and welcome to another episode of how we made your mother.
大家好，欢迎收看另一期《我们是如何认识你母亲的》。
I'm Josh Radner.
我是乔什·拉德纳。
I am joined as ever by my friend Craig Thomas.
和往常一样，我的老友克雷格·托马斯也来到了现场。
Hello Josh, honored to be here.
哈喽，乔什，很荣幸来到这里。
Oh my gosh.
哦，天哪。
So we're discussing this TV show that we made together for many, many years.
我们在讨论这个我们一起制作了很多很多年的电视剧。
It was called How I Met Your Mother.
它叫《老爸老妈的浪漫史》。
It ran from 2005 to 2014.
它从2005年一直播到2014年。
We often say we're having a very special episode of How We Made Your Mother, but this week it is a special, special, extra special episode because we are joined by the one and only Cobi Smolders.
我们经常说这是一期非常特殊的《我们是如何认识你母亲的》，但本周这期节目特别、特别、格外特殊，因为我们迎来了独一无二的寇碧·史莫德斯。
Hi, Cobs.
嗨，科布斯。
Hi, Cubs.
So good to see you.
很高兴见到你。
Hello, everyone.
大家好。
What's the best?
太棒了。
Oh, hi guys.
哦，嗨，伙计们。
I'm so happy to be here.
我很高兴能来到这里。
Oh, the best of the best.
哦，棒极了。
We're so happy to hang out with you guys.
我们也很高兴能和你们一起聊天。
So we just heard the compilation of Robin and Cobi loving voices from all over the world.
我们刚刚听到了世界各地粉丝对罗宾和寇碧的表白合集。
This is the first time we heard it, but I'm so curious.
这是我们第一次听到，但我很好奇。
How was that for you to hear all that love coming at you?
听到这么多的爱意向你涌来，你有什么感觉？
you.
你。
You know, I am not great with compliments.
你知道的，我不太擅长应付赞美。
There wasn't hell on earth.
那可不是人间地狱。
It was all on earth.
那是人间天堂。
It's like, I mean, it's so, first of all, it's so lovely.
我的意思是，首先，这太美妙了。
And it's, you know, I think, I feel like what you guys have really been discussing on this podcast, podcast thus far.
你知道的，我觉得这就像你们俩在这个播客中一直在探讨的话题一样。
And what I can also sort of speak to is like the love of this show, the love that people have for these characters and what an amazing thing to be a part of the show that brought people so much joy and so much entertainment and also like a sort of a way to funnel what they're going through themselves.
我也能感同身受的是，大家对这部剧的爱，人们对这些角色的爱，能成为一部给人们带来如此多欢乐、娱乐以及情感宣泄出口的剧集的一部分，是一件多么了不起的事。
And it's wild and it's a wonderful legacy to be a part of.
这太疯狂了，能成为这样一段美妙传奇的一部分让我倍感荣幸。
So any time I get a compliment I kind of stored in that how I met your mother bank in terms of like what every member of our cast crew, writers, producers, we all made together.
所以每当我得到赞美，我都会把它存进《老爸老妈的浪漫史》的记忆银行里，这是我们剧组所有演员、幕后人员、编剧和制片人共同创造的成果。
I just feel it's such a wonderful, it's a gift that keeps on giving and I'm so I'm so lucky to be the recipient of it.
我只觉得这一切太美妙了，这是一个不断给予的礼物，能成为它的收件人我真的非常幸运。
Well, let me ask you one of the things we're interrogating on the show is just like why how I made my mother stuck around, why people, why it's minting new fans every year, why people watch it and re-watch it and re-watch it, what the fervor is and the devotion to the show and the characters, what that's really about.
好吧，让我问你一个我们在节目中探讨的问题：为什么《老爸老妈的浪漫史》能经久不衰？为什么每年都有新粉丝入坑？为什么人们一遍又一遍地反复观看？这种狂热和对剧集及角色的忠诚背后究竟是什么？
Has it shocked you the kind of long tail of the show?
这部剧的超长生命力有没有让你感到震惊？
Because sometimes you'll do something and it's nice when it's on and then it kind of goes away, it fades into kind of the pop culture memory bank.
因为有时你拍完一部作品，播出时感觉不错，然后它就会逐渐淡出，消逝在流行文化的记忆库中。
But this one just feels very alive for people.
但这部剧对大家来说依然充满活力。
Do you feel that in your own life, like when people approach you and talk to you and want to talk about the show, and also has it surprised you how long it stuck around?
你在现实生活中能感受到这一点吗？比如当人们走近你、跟你聊天、想聊聊这部剧的时候，而且它播完这么久依然热度不减，这有没有让你感到惊讶？
Yeah, it's certainly been a surprise.
是的，这确实让我感到意外。
I think there are different layers that happen, right?
我觉得这里面有不同的层次，对吧？
There are people who are R-H who are like, I remember being in my 20s watching this show.
有些人会说：“我记得我20多岁的时候就在看这部剧。”
And you're like, yeah, same, same.
然后你就会说：“对啊，我也是，我也是。”
And it feels like relatable, and then I'll meet somebody who's like 15.
这让人觉得很有共鸣，然后我会遇到一个15岁的小朋友。
I'm like, you were not a person then.
我会想：“你那时候根本还不是个人。”
You were not, you did not exist, you caught around.
你那时候根本不存在，你还没出生呢。
And so I find that really interesting where it's multi-generational.
所以我发现这种跨代际的现象非常有趣。
And I think that, you know, I don't know what the secret sauce is that you and Carter did, Craig.
我觉得，克雷格，你和卡特当年的秘制配方我不得而知。
I mean, I think it's like, first of all, we got to do it for nine years.
我的意思是，首先，我们拍了九年。
So we had so much time to make people really know these characters, to play out so many different storylines.
所以我们有充足的时间让观众真正了解这些角色，演绎那么多不同的故事线。
And like, I just don't feel like that's something people are able to do on television anymore.
而且，我觉得现在的电视剧演员很难再有这种机会了。
You know, we were able to sort of practice and find and really hone in who these characters were and the world that they were in, which we were so lucky to do.
你知道的，我们能够去练习、探索并真正打磨这些角色的特质以及他们所处的那个世界，我们真的非常幸运。
But it's, I find that the younger generation really fascinating because, and I talk to them sometimes, I talk to kids, I can call them kids, because they're, you know, we're there.
但我发现年轻一代真的很有意思，有时我会跟他们交流，我跟孩子们聊天——我可以叫他们孩子，因为他们，你知道的，我们就在那儿。
Because it doesn't make us want to know, I know, I know, I know, we're Bob Sagan now, we are now officially future Ted, like we speak like, when these kids come up to me, and you know, they say I just watched the whole series this weekend or something really wild, You know, I'm like, it must be so strange because dating has changed so much.
因为这让我们想知道——我知道，我知道，我现在成了鲍勃·萨格，我们现在正式成了未来的泰德——每当这些孩子们跑来对我说，你知道的，他们说“我这个周末刚看完整部剧”或者类似这种疯狂的话时，你知道的，我会想，对于他们来说一定很奇怪，因为现在的约会方式已经发生了翻天覆地的变化。
You know, like, and I'm like, what is that like to watch these characters, you know, leave messages on an answering machine?
你知道的，我会想：看这些角色在答录机上留言是一种什么体验？
And then you have like, wait till you get home to like check the answering machine and then hope that like, oh, I'm 10 minutes late cause I just got this message at this time and meet them in the bar.
然后你还得等回到家去检查答录机留言，然后祈祷着：“哦，我迟到了10分钟，因为我刚刚在这个时间收到了这条留言，然后去酒吧见他们。”
Like there is, I think that there's something obviously more romantic in that world meeting people, but they seem to really connect to it and kind of love it and it doesn't feel strange to them.
我觉得，在那个世界里人们相识的方式显然更具浪漫色彩，但他们似乎真的能与之产生共鸣并喜爱它，并不觉得这有什么奇怪。
But it's not how they do it.
但这确实不是他们现在的恋爱方式。
And I do think that generally romantics do love the show.
而且我确实认为，浪漫主义者通常都非常喜欢这部剧。
I think that that is sort of a common thread, people who really believe in love and romance and grand gestures and really wanting to find somebody special to spend their whole life with.
我觉得这是一个共同点，那些真正相信爱、相信浪漫、相信宏大告白、真心想要找个特别的人共度一生的人。
It's like, I do find that that is a through line, which is obviously very apparent in our show.
我发现这确实是一条贯穿始终的主线，这在我们的剧集中显然非常明显。
But yeah, I think it hits people in different ways.
不过是的，我觉得它以各种不同的方式触动了人们的心灵。
And I think that the characters you guys created really filled so many different areas of interest for people.
而且我认为你们创作的角色确实满足了很多人不同的兴趣点。
So there was always somebody that they could latch onto and have a favorite of.
所以总有一个角色是他们能抓住并作为最爱的。
And I wrote you this little diddy to send to you.
我为你写了这首小曲要发给你。
to you in New York City will be right back.
发给纽约市的你，我们马上回来。
Hey, I'm Carl Radke.
嘿，我是卡尔·拉德克。
You might know me from Bravo Summer House, but on my podcast, More Life, I get your favorite reality stars off the clock and into the conversations you don't usually get to hear.
你可能在 Bravo 电视台的《夏日山庄》里认识我，但在我的播客《更多生活》中，我让你们最喜欢的真人秀明星们暂避镁光灯，进入那些你平时听不到的对话。
The deep stuff, the vulnerable stuff, the uncomfortable stuff.
那些深刻的事情，那些脆弱的事情，那些让人不自在的事情。
I've sat down with Sierra Miller, Derinda Medley, Tom Schwartz, Lindsey Hubbard, and a whole lot more.
我采访过席亚拉·米勒、德林达·梅德利、汤姆·施瓦茨、林赛·哈伯德等等很多人。
We get into relationships growing up, the messy stuff, and everything that happens when the cameras aren't rolling.
我们探讨成长过程中的恋爱关系、那些一团糟的事，以及摄像机没拍到时发生的一切。
New episodes of more life every week, listen wherever you get your podcasts or watch on YouTube.
每周都有《更多生活》的新节目，在各大播客平台收听或在 YouTube 上观看。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目中。
I'm curious to ask you something, Kobe, which is in our first episode of this podcast, we sort of talked about this from Josh's perspective.
科比，我很好奇想问你一件事，就是在这个播客的第一期节目中，我们曾从乔什的角度探讨过这个问题。
But what it was like for you to kind of like, meet that character on the page, before you met me or Carter or Pam or anything else, like you see this on the page, you know you're gonna come in audition for it.
但对你来说，在见到我、卡特、帕姆或其他任何人之前，在剧本上初次遇到那个角色是什么感觉？就像你在剧本上看到这个，你知道你要来试镜。
Remember our casting director, Megan Brandman was like, this is somebody really interesting.
还记得我们的选角导演梅根·布兰德曼当时说，这是一个非常有趣的人。
This is somebody you're gonna take really seriously for this role, and I give her a lot of credit, Megan, for really perking us up to pay attention here.
这是一个你会为这个角色认真对待的人，我非常感谢梅根，是他提醒了我们要特别关注这一点。
This is somebody special, you were very young, you had not done any comedy, I don't think, right?
这是一个特别的人，你当时很年轻，我记得你之前没演过喜剧吧？
You had been on some hour shows?
你之前演过一些一小时时长的剧集？
I'm just curious to hear your perspective of finding that script, coming in that audition, meeting that character, meeting us, and kind of where, what that felt like from your perspective.
我很好奇想听听你的视角：发现那个剧本、来参加试镜、遇到那个角色、遇到我们，从你的角度来看，那是一种什么样的感觉。
We talked about that with Joshua, he came in, he remembered the office, he came in an audition which I think it was the same one you came in, but what do you remember of that?
我们和约书亚聊过这个，他来了，他记得那个办公室，他来试镜——我想跟你们来的是同一个，但你对那有什么记忆？
Pan as little word picture there.
帕姆在那用语言描绘了一幅画。
Yeah, let's go back.
好吧，我们回想一下。
So I was and still am very Canadian.
所以我当时是，现在也依然非常加拿大。
I think I'm still 23.
我觉得我好像还是23岁。
So I was living in Canada and we would do this sort of Canadian migration every year because there was a pilot season.
所以当时我住在加拿大，我们每年都会进行这种所谓的加拿大候鸟式迁徙，因为当时有试播集季。
And so you would, I would, you know, I worked in restaurants all year and I saved up money.
所以你会，我会，你知道的，我整年都在餐馆打工攒钱。
And then I drove my Volkswagen Jetta, Sadie, Mashi Rest in Peace.
然后我开着我的大众捷达，萨迪，马希，愿她安息。
Sadie, I never knew this.
萨迪，我从来不知道这件事。
See, we're breaking news here.
看，我们这有独家新闻。
Sadie.
萨迪。
You know what I mean?
你知道我的意思吗？
Everyone's know my first heart.
每个人都知道我的初恋。
You can't imagine the amount of you or male we've gotten about this.
你无法想象我们收到了多少关于这件事的粉丝邮件。
So we're thrilled.
所以我们太兴奋了。
It's mostly the answer, the top question.
这基本上是大家问得最多的问题。
Thanks for being with us, Kobe.
谢谢你和我们在一起，科比。
This was so wonderful.
这太棒了。
I was right.
我猜得没错。
You guys are so nice to see everyone.
你们见到大家真好。
No, me and Sadie Lady, we drove down and, you know, I lived with two of my best friends in Venice when it was not nice.
不，我和萨迪小姐，我们开车南下，你知道的，我和我最好的两个朋友住在威尼斯海滩，当时那里还不是什么好地方。
Venice, Abbot Kinney when it was not fancy.
威尼斯，阿伯特金尼大道，当时还很不高级的时候。
And, you know, we just auditioned like crazy.
你知道的，我们就是疯狂地去试镜。
you would do, you know, if you were lucky, you would get multiple auditions a week a day.
如果你幸运的话，你一周甚至一天会得到好几次试镜机会。
And it was kind of madness.
那简直有点疯狂。
It was kind of like a, you know, this fever dream of, you know, getting eight pages of sides to memorize for the next day.
这就像是一种狂热的梦境，要为第二天背诵八页的台词。
And just hoping that something would click and then, you know, networks were making multiple pilots every year.
然后只是祈祷能有哪个角色合适，然后，你知道的，电视台每年都在制作好几个试播集。
So you would kind of go like, okay, I'll get a pilot maybe.
所以你大概会想，好吧，我可能会拿到一个试播集。
and then I'll at least, you know, and for me being a Canadian, being an immigrant, I was like, please God, get me a job down here so I can stay.
然后我至少能……对我来说，作为加拿大人，作为一个移民，我就在想：求求上帝，让我在南方找个工作吧，这样我才能留下来。
So I came down, I drove down, and I was auditioning for multiple pilots, and I think I was set to test for something, which I can't remember, but I do think that Mark Paul Glosser, who was who played Zach Morris, was in this other pilot, so I was really excited because I didn't very much in love with him for a majority of my teenage life.
所以我南下了，我开车过来，我为好几个试播集试镜，我想我当时准备为某个剧试镜，我不记得是什么了，但我确实觉得马克-保罗·戈塞拉——也就是扮演扎克·莫里斯的那个人——也在另一个试播集中，所以我当时非常兴奋，因为在我的青少年时期大部分时间里，我都非常迷恋他。
Wait, a pilot against, at the same time as the average mother pilot isn't?
等等，一个试播集对立着——与此同时《老爸老妈浪漫史》的试播集不是吗？
Yeah, before I had even met you, I had auditioned for this, Zach Morris, we're not gonna call him that, but like, I'm sorry, that's like, like, of Mark, okay, we'll call him Mark by his actual name, Mark, and to play his sister, and I was like, this is confusing because I'm very much in love with, like, I spent a majority of my teen years, very much in love with this human.
对，甚至在我遇到你之前，我曾为这个试播集试镜，扎克·莫里斯，我们不这么叫他，但就像是，对不起，那就是——马克，好吧，我们用他的真名叫他马克，去演他的妹妹，我就觉得这很让人困惑，因为我非常迷恋，我度过了大部分青少年时期，都非常迷恋这个人类。
So I was set, they were doing sort of, I think, Josh, you sort of spoke to everybody about the testing process.
所以我当时准备好了，他们正在进行某种——我想，约什你跟大家都聊过试播测试的过程。
So I won't bore everybody with like network studio and all that stuff.
所以我不会用电视台、制片厂以及所有那些事情来烦大家了。
But I was set to test with him and then got a call from Megan and stuff and went in and read.
但我当时准备和马克一起测试，然后接到了梅根的电话，然后就去读了剧本。
And then I said, you know, I'm testing for this other show.
然后我说，你知道的，我正在为另一部剧做测试。
And then I think like that she brought me in like the next day to meet with you guys.
然后我想她第二天就把我叫来跟你们见面了。
Oh my God.
天哪。
I don't think I ever knew this.
我想我以前从来不知道这件事。
I'm feeling this weird emotion.
我有一种奇怪的情绪。
Like I'm slightly jealous of Mark Paul, Goss, I don't know where it's going to be.
就像我有点嫉妒马克·保罗·戈斯，我不知道这会走向何方。
I'm like, get away from Kobe.
我就想：离科比远点！
She's going to be our Robin.
她会是我们的罗宾。
I'm like having a whole time travel thing.
我感觉自己像是在经历一次时空旅行。
No, yes.
不，是的。
That's hilarious.
这太搞笑了。
She was sort of fast-tracked to me.
她基本上是被快速引荐给我的。
And she was like, okay, we'll come in tomorrow and you can meet Kari and Craig.
她说，好吧，你明天来，可以见见卡里和克雷格。
And I was like, we're right.
我就想：好的。
And so I met you guys and immediately, like to felt like this is really funny, but as you had said, Greg, I had never done a comedy.
于是我见到了你们，立刻就觉得这真的很有趣，但正如你所说的那样，克雷格，我从来没有演过喜剧。
I've done sort of hour long dramas, mostly up in Canada.
我以前在加拿大演过大约一小时时长的正剧。
And so I was not sure if I was funny.
所以我并不确定自己是否有幽默感。
I mean, I think I could make friends and family laugh, but it was a different, it was a different rhythm And it was a different sort of demand.
我的意思是，我觉得我能让朋友和家人笑，但那是完全不同的节奏，也是完全不同的要求。
And so I tried my best, and I guess I fooled ya.
所以我尽力了，我想我骗过你们了。
I fooled ya.
我骗过你们了。
And only for nine years though.
不过只骗了九年。
So you really didn't do a good job.
所以你其实也没做好。
Good.
很好。
I don't know when you're gonna pull the plug out.
我不知道你什么时候会拔掉插头。
It's still working.
它仍然在运作。
I still think you're funny.
我还是觉得你很有趣。
Yeah, and then it was sort of a similar process.
是的，然后这是一个类似的过程。
I remember meeting Josh, but we were lucky enough to do the studio network test together.
我记得见过约什，但我们很幸运能一起参加制片厂和电视台的测试。
And it felt very, it felt very lovely and very easy.
感觉非常可爱，也非常轻松。
And it was, I think probably the best version of that process can be.
这可以说是那个流程中最完美的形式了。
I felt very, when I read the script for the first time, I just, I fell in love.
当我第一次读到这个剧本时，我真的坠入爱河了。
I mean, Robin isn't in the pilot very much if I'm, like she's sort of, it's more about this group of people.
我的意思是，如果我没记错的话，罗宾在试播集里戏份并不多，她差不多是……这集更多是关于这一群人的。
And I remember being like, oh gosh, hope I can stay and become a part of this group.
我记得当时在想：哦天哪，希望我能留下来，成为这群人中的一员。
But I thought she was, and even in the opening, people saying she's so confident.
但我觉得她，甚至在一开始，大家就说她太自信了。
And I didn't feel like that at all.
而我一点也没有那种感觉。
I was very much acting.
我完全是在演。
Well, what's funny is the plot of the first two episodes of How Much Mother is this young woman from Canada hopes she can come to America and become part of this friend group.
有趣的是，《老爸老妈浪漫史》前两集的剧情就是这个来自加拿大的年轻女性希望她能来到美国并成为这个朋友圈的一部分。
And you actually it felt exactly the way that was what the character felt and what you thought.
而你当时的感觉完全就是那个角色所感受到的，也是你当时所想的。
But to be fair, she was not Canadian yet.
但公平地说，她当时还不是加拿大人。
You made her Canadian.
你们把她设定成了加拿大人。
No, it's true.
不，确实如此。
We didn't.
我们没有。
We made her Canadian in honor of you.
我们为了向你致敬，才把她设定为加拿大人。
That's true.
没错。
You know, I do sometimes think that when you get a role that is kind of like a role that kind of becomes iconic, like our roles all became, there is something about that it feels bigger than just, oh, you were right for the part.
你知道，有时我确实认为，当你得到一个某种程度上会成为标志性的角色时——就像我们所有的角色最终都成为的那样，这里面有些东西感觉比单纯的“你很适合这个角色”要宏大得多。
Like it feels like your DNA was right for the part.
就好像你的基因天生就适合这个角色一样。
like there's a mystical thing that happens.
就像有什么神秘的事情在发生。
And even as Craig lays it out, it's like, yeah, you were acting, you were doing these things, but you were also like, where you were in your life on the earth at that moment, was exactly what was required for the show.
即使在克雷格（Craig）剖析之后，也会觉得，是的，你在演戏，你在做这些事情，但同时，你当时在人生的那个阶段、在地球上所处的位置，恰好就是这部剧所需要的。
And where I was in my life thing was exactly what was needed in the show.
我当时在人生中的状态，恰好就是这部剧所需要的。
So it's almost like, yes, acting's hard landing jokes is challenging and all that.
所以这几乎就像是，是的，演戏很难，抖包袱很有挑战性，诸如此类。
You're technically doing things.
你在技术上确实在做这些事情。
But there's also something where you're like, You can't actually screw it up.
但某种程度上，你会觉得，你其实根本不会搞砸。
If you're that right for the role, you're just going to be the person, you know?
如果你和这个角色如此契合，你自然就会成为那个人，你知道吗？
And you were.
而你确实就是。
And that's the thing.
这就是关键所在。
We never wanted anybody else for the part once we saw you.
一旦我们见到了你，我们就再没想过让其他人来演这个角色。
It was just how do we convince a network that is going to say, what else has she done in terms of comedy?
问题只在于，我们该如何说服电视网，他们肯定会问：“她在喜剧方面还演过什么？”
What's her real?
“她的真实水平是什么？”
Where are all her clips?
“她的喜剧片段都在哪儿？”
And we had to make the point in this show, it's a character meeting this woman out of nowhere.
而我们必须在这部剧中指出这一点：这是一个角色在酒吧里偶遇一个突如其来的女人。
And wouldn't it be nice for America to also be meeting this woman?
那让全美观众也偶遇这样一位女性，不是也挺好的吗？
They've never seen on other sitcoms.
他们从未在其他情景喜剧中见过她。
She hasn't done 12 other sitcoms.
她没有拍过另外12部情景喜剧。
this is her first one and that's a good thing.
这是她的第一部，而这绝对是件好事。
And they got it.
他们理解了。
So they're credit.
所以这要归功于他们。
Then I work in the studio.
后来我在制片厂工作。
They got, they got that that's Ted.
他们懂了，他们明白泰德（Ted）当时在吧台对面遇到了她，全美观众也是如此，这感觉就像是命中注定。
Ted was meeting her in that moment across the bar and so was America and it felt meant to be.
真的就是这样。
It really did.
真的如此。
I think it's also, I hear you Josh, but I think it's also like the credit goes to you and Carter as well.
我也觉得，乔治（Josh），我听到你的话了，但我认为荣誉也应该归功于你和卡特（Carter）。
And also I will say Pam Fryman, like there was this sort of very safe environment.
而且我还要感谢帕姆·弗莱曼（Pam Fryman），当时有一种非常安全的环境。
environment.
环境。
You know, the credit also would go to the studio CBS and Fox because they didn't notice to death.
你知道，荣誉也应该归功于CBS电视台和福克斯制片厂，因为他们没有对我们进行过度干涉。
So when we're taping and we're recording all these things, first of all, you're surrounded by amazing actors.
所以当我们拍摄和录制所有这些内容时，首先，你的周围都是优秀的演员。
You have Pam Fryman, who's like mother to, I mean, for me, and I think a lot of other people on that set would say that as well.
你有帕姆·弗莱曼，她就像是大家的母亲，我是说，对我而言，我想片场的许多其他人也会这样说。
you know, it created this especially for someone like me who was quite terrified and really sort of working with these other actors who were so funny and so talented and had done so much more than I had.
你知道，这创造了一种氛围，尤其是对于像我这样感到十分恐惧、而且真的需要和这些其他演员合作的人来说，他们是如此风趣、如此才华横溢，而且比我经验丰富得多。
I felt a lot of pressure and it was this wonderful environment to step into to be like, yeah, you can totally bomb and then we'll just do another take and then it'll get better.
我感到了巨大的压力，但能走进这样一个美妙的环境，听到“没关系，你完全可以演砸，然后我们再拍一条，就会变得更好”，这种感觉真好。
You know, And so I felt very, I felt very lucky to step into that world and being held by that group of people in such a wonderful way.
你知道，所以我感到非常非常幸运能走进那个世界，并被那一群人以如此美妙的方式包容和支持着。
Hey, Kobe, this is just a memory I'm having.
嘿，寇碧（Cobie），我突然想起了的一段回忆。
Do you remember we had been cast UNI and I don't know that anyone else had been cast at that point.
你还记得吗，当时你和我已经通过试镜被选中了，我不知道当时是不是还有其他人进组。
Maybe Neil had been cast, but you and I grabbed dinner at the authentic cafe, which was like a block from my apartment, this Mexican restaurant.
也许尼尔（Neil）当时已经入选了，但你和我去了一家名叫 Authentic Cafe 的墨西哥餐厅吃晚饭，它离我的公寓只有一个街区远。
And you, we were kind of celebrating that we were about to do this show, this pilot together, but you had just met Taren, right?
然后我们有点像是在庆祝我们即将一起出演这部剧、这个试播集，但你当时刚刚认识塔伦（Taren），对吧？
Like you were right about, it was like, it's fascinating to me that these two very much life-defining events, meaning your future husband and getting cast on the show, which you would do for nearly a decade, they were all, that was sort of busy couple months for you, right?
就像是，当时你正处于……在我看来，这两件对人生具有决定意义的大事，也就是遇到你未来的丈夫和获得这部你将参演近十年的剧集，它们都在同一时期发生，对你来说那真是忙碌的几个月，对吧？
I mean, your life really, really changed quite a bit.
我是说，你的生活真的发生了相当大的改变。
Yeah, and I was 22, I was very young and Yeah, but Taren and I met, I think maybe the week before we started shooting, something a lot like that.
是的，我当时22岁，非常年轻，而且……是的，但塔伦和我相遇，我想大概是在我们开拍前一周左右，差不多就是那样。
And he was also in pilot season two, so there was this weird, you know, like, is this going to go?
而且他当时也正处于试播集选角季，所以有一种奇怪的……你知道的，那种“这剧能被预订吗？”
Is that going to go kind of energy?
“那部剧能行吗？”的焦虑氛围。
But yeah.
不过是的。
Taren's glad you didn't get the Zack Morris show either.
塔伦应该庆幸你当年也没有拿到扎克·莫里斯（Zack Morris）的那部剧。
You never could have married you, you would have been unavailable having, having fake incest with sack.
否则他根本没法娶你，你当时就会分身乏术，跟扎克上演伪乱伦剧情了。
Oh, yeah, I mean, I guess that show didn't go.
噢，对，我是说，我猜那部剧后来没拍成。
I don't even know what it was, but I just remember that.
我甚至不知道那是什么剧，但我只记得这件事。
I'm kind of picturing your energy with him.
我脑海里能想象出你当时对他的那种状态。
Had you been cast in that would be very much like the James Vanderbeek episode.
如果你当时参演了那部剧，感觉就会非常像詹姆斯·范德比克（James Van Der Beek）那集。
Oh my gosh.
哦天哪。
Yes.
是的。
By the way, I want to point out I did not forget the robot.
顺便说一句，我想指出我并没有忘记那个机器人。
I just needed to we're just sitting here.
我只是需要……我们刚才就坐在这里。
I just wanted to make sure as soon as you came on, I saw it And I freaking out internally, but I didn't want it to be the first thing that I started talking about.
我只是想确保，你一出场我就看到了它，我内心激动得要命，但我不想把它当作我们开始谈话的第一个话题。
I felt like we had to build up to it.
我觉得我们得先铺垫一下。
And I'm, I'm glad that we're here now because I've been waiting for 20 minutes.
而且我很高兴我们现在聊到这里了，因为我已经等了20分钟了。
I just wanted you to know.
我只是想让你知道。
It's a tribute to you.
这是对你的致敬。
He's as handsome as ever.
他还是和以前一样帅。
That little devil.
那个小恶魔。
He says hi.
他说他向你问好。
Yeah, he dressed up for you.
对，他特地为你盛装打扮了。
You know, I was wondering about Kobe too, like in the opening where we heard those amazing comments about the love for you and the love for Robin that you've very deftly dodged and compartmentalized somehow not to take any of it as a compliment for you.
你知道，寇碧，我也一直在想，比如在开场时我们听到那些关于大家对你的爱、对罗宾（Robin）的爱的精彩评价，你非常巧妙地避开了，并把它们归类隔离，不知怎么地，没有把其中任何一句当成是对你个人的赞美。
We're going back to it now or I'm going to insist that you take some of it.
我们现在要重新谈起这个，我要坚持让你接受其中的一部分。
I mean, I'm bringing you back.
我是说，我要把你拉回来。
If you don't cry today, we're going to consider this a failure.
如果你今天不哭的话，我们就要把这视为一次失败。
Okay.
好吧。
Cool.
太棒了。
I was going to say that I literally get into each one individually.
我本来想说，我真的是在逐一细细品味每一条评论。
I started to cry a little bit during that, and I don't know where you were during that, but like, it's, they were amazing.
刚才听到那些时，我其实有点想哭，我不知道你当时在哪儿，但那些评价真的太棒了。
And I hope you take that in, because there's the love for you and Robin.
我希望你能把这些听进心里，因为大家对你和罗宾的喜爱真的是太深了。
It's so amazing.
太惊人了。
Hearing that one comment where they talked about how Robin was like, she's the gun toting this and the list of, you know, Canadian and gun to none of those lists.
听到其中有一条评论说罗宾是那种……她是什么持枪的……然后列举了一堆，你知道的，加拿大和枪械之类的东西，而这些标签在那些列表里全都没有。
All of these were things we didn't know when we met you about Robin, right?
所有这些都是我们在遇到你之前所不知道的关于罗宾的特质，对吧？
Yeah, to be clear, I know it's only a gun though.
是的，澄清一下，我知道其实只有一把枪。
I'm very, it's not as Robin.
我很清楚，这并不是罗宾的全部。
Yes, I know.
是的，我知道。
We can debate the complexity of that you're character trade later No, but but like it kind of a question of both you and Josh from me.
我们稍后再讨论你角色特质的复杂性，不过——不，但对我来说，这其实是一个想同时抛给你和乔治的问题。
This isn't always interesting to me like We we these characters didn't arrive fully formed on the page.
这对我来说总是很有趣，我们……这些角色在剧本上并非一开始就完全成型的。
They arrived We all met them together and then this journey of getting to do nine seasons is such a gift Creatively for writers and actors and it's such a collaboration I think between writers and actors you guys bring these energies to it and some of yourselves do it you being Canadian and for Robin being Canadian, what is it like as an actor to sort of start with one thing and then kind of find all these other things?
他们是一步步到来的，我们所有人一起与他们相识，然后经历长达九季的创作旅程，这对于编剧和演员来说简直是一份巨大的创意礼物，而且我认为这是编剧和演员之间的一种绝佳合作，你们为角色注入了这些活力，甚至融入了你们自己的一部分——比如你是加拿大人，罗宾也是加拿大人，作为一名演员，一开始只有一个雏形，然后慢慢发现所有这些其他的特质，这是一种怎样的体验？
Or you get a script one day and you go, oh, I guess there's this other side to Robin.
或者某天你拿到剧本，然后心想，“哦，原来罗宾还有这样一面，我得把这个融入进去。”
I have to incorporate that in.
而且你知道其中一部分灵感来自于我们——也就是编剧们——是如何看待你的。
And you know some of it's coming from how we the writers are seeing you.
我们在观察你的举动。
We're seeing what you do.
随着一季又一季的播出，这种通过探索达成的合作是怎样的体验？
What does that collaboration of that discovery like over seasons?
因为随着剧情发展，我们对罗宾的了解越来越多。
Because Robin, we find out a lot more about Robin.
我们在第一季时并不知道罗宾曾是个流行歌星，身后还藏着我身旁这个机器人。
We did not know Robin was a pop star with this robot behind me in season one.
我们也不知道罗宾和她父亲有着如此复杂纠结的关系，但随着时间推移，我们得以深入挖掘：为什么罗宾会是现在的罗宾？
We did not know Robin had this incredibly complicated relationship with her father, but over time we got to dig into like, why is Robin Robin, what is that like for you as an actor to play that and sort of find those things and incorporate those as you go along?
作为一名演员，去演绎这些内容、发掘这些特质，并在前进的过程中将它们融入角色，这是一种怎样的体验？
It's wonderful.
这太美妙了。
It's such a wonderful thing.
这真的是一件极其美妙的事情。
And I think it's sort of a, you know, an easing into the character.
而且我认为这有点像是一个……你知道的，逐渐融入角色的过程。
And we had such an amazing writer's room.
我们拥有一个如此优秀的编剧团队。
And they were so talented, so funny, so intuitive, and I became very good friends with a lot of those writers.
他们是如此才华横溢、风趣幽默、极具直觉，我和许多编剧都成为了非常要好的朋友。
Gloria Calderon-Callet is one of my best friends to this day.
格洛丽亚·卡尔德隆·凯莱特（Gloria Calderon-Kellet）至今仍是我最好的朋友之一。
And I think it's, I became friends with a lot of them, and then for better or worse, they would take some of my tics, like the buddham thing.
我认为，我成了他们许多人的朋友，然后不管好坏，他们会把我的某些口头禅写进剧里，比如那个“buddham”的口癖。
I think just the thing I would do.
我觉得那就是我会做的事。
And they they added that I also think there was a couple jabs at my it's literally the worst thing I've ever heard.
他们把它加了进去，而且我还觉得，他们对我的……“这绝对是我听过最烂的事情了”这句话也做了一些调侃。
Did we, you know, that was the thing that I did I would do.
我们，你知道的，那就是我过去常常会做的事。
And my 20s, like, I forgot that those were those us taking your things.
在我20多岁的时候，我都忘了那是我们在借用你的习惯。
I guess they were.
我想他们是的。
Did we ask you permission or did you just get it on the page and be like, look at these motherfuckers.
是我们问过你的许可，还是你刚好看到剧本，然后觉得，看看这帮混蛋。
We just know you just roll it straight on, roll it, just started digging, just started digging.
我们只知道你直接就演了，直接开演，开始挖掘，开始挖掘。
So I guess those late night at like those late night nights at the bar on the set, really, really, that's when they home their best material.
所以我猜那些深夜在酒吧、在片场的夜晚，真的是他们打磨最好素材的时候。
But I know it is so important.
但我知道这非常重要。
It's so important.
这太重要了。
It's such a gift because like you don't, you know, again, speaking to doing something for nine years, doing a project that that's that long-running and also something in the industry, if we're talking comparatively of the shows of that time, I feel like how I met your mother did and what you guys did was constant give us new and exciting stories to do.
这真是一份大礼，因为你不会……你知道的，还是说到演了九年，参与一个如此长寿的项目，而且在业界中，如果我们拿那个时期的剧集来做对比，我觉得《老爸老妈浪漫史》以及你们所做到的，就是不断给我们提供新鲜、精彩的故事去演绎。
And speaking solely about, you know, the character of Robin, like, she was on so many different news.
单单聊到罗宾这个角色，她做过那么多不同的新闻节目。
She had so many love interests.
她有过那么多的感情线。
Like, she had, she dated so many people.
她约会过那么多人。
And then it was, I remember when you presented me with the Robin Sparkles thing.
然后就是，我还记得当你们向我提出“罗宾·什帕克尔斯”这个设定的时候。
And even before that, when you're like, we're thinking about making Robin a Canadian.
甚至在此之前，你们说，我们在考虑让罗宾成为一个加拿大人。
And I was like, oh, okay, that's cool.
当时我说，哦，好吧，挺酷的。
And you said, you were harder said, we're thinking of making our Canadian because we think it's exotic.
而你当时说——更确切地说是你们说——我们在考虑让她成为加拿大人，因为我们觉得这很异国情调。
And I, as long as I'm myself, and I have never been called a lot of exotic as exotic in my life.
而我当时想，只要能做我自己就行，而且我这辈子从来没被人叫过什么异国情调。
And so I found that really funny.
所以我当时觉得这真的太搞笑了。
And I think you guys gave me one speech that was talking about universal healthcare school systems are anti-gun, you know, legislation.
而且我觉得你们给过我一段台词，是讲全民医疗保健、学校系统、反枪支立法什么的。
And then it was one speech.
然后就只有那么一段台词。
It was maybe 11.
大概是第11集吧。
I see it in my mind.
我脑子里有画面。
It was like 11 because I was so excited to say it.
好像就是第11集，因为我当时太兴奋了，特别想把它说出来。
I was like, so because we're Canadian.
我就想，因为我们是加拿大人。
I know exactly what you're talking about.
我完全知道你在说什么。
We're talking flag down.
我们当时在说亮明国旗。
I think we said, we're going to be doing this all the time in Canada to show how great my country is.
我觉得我们当时说的是，我们在加拿大总是这么做，来展示我的国家有多伟大。
I cannot wait.
我等不及了。
I have so much national pride.
我有这么强烈的民族自豪感。
I was so excited.
我当时兴奋极了。
and I got one speech and the rest were like, like my accent jokes, like maple syrup jokes, lover of hockey jokes.
结果我只分到了一段正经台词，剩下的全都是我的口音笑话、枫糖浆笑话、曲棍球爱好者的笑话。
The doughnuts.
还有甜甜圈。
And I will say thank goodness you had Chuck Tatham on your on your writing.
我得说，谢天谢地你们的编剧团队里有查克·塔瑟姆。
So yeah, Canadian specialist, Canadian specialist writer, yeah, writing the real details, yeah, and often like conferring with you on how to get that right.
所以，没错，加拿大专家、加拿大专业编剧，没错，写出了真正的细节，而且经常向你请教怎么把这些细节写对。
Well, and Susie Greenberg was Canadian our producers, Susie Greenberg, we had a lot of We're around, we might be sneaky, but we're around.
对，还有苏茜·格林伯格也是加拿大人，我们的制片人苏茜·格林伯格，我们剧组有很多……我们无处不在，我们可能神神秘秘的，但我们一直都在。
You're very exotic, I still don't understand you all.
你们太有异国情调了，我到现在也搞不懂你们。
And we are here.
而我们就在这里。
It was so much love for Canada in that room.
那个房间里对加拿大充满了爱。
I started God and I love that Canada loves the show.
天哪，我太爱加拿大喜欢这部剧这一点了。
And I would not have had it any other way.
如果重来一次，我绝不希望有任何改变。
Canadians can take a punch, really.
加拿大人真的很经得起开玩笑。
Canadians take a punch.
加拿大人很开得起玩笑。
Oh, they're the best sense of humor ever.
哦，他们有着史上最好的幽默感。
Yeah.
对。
You know, one thing that Craig has mentioned a few times is that that every other character was tangentially based on someone, Ted on Carter and Marshall and Lily on Craig and Rebecca, and Robin was the character they just kind of imagined out of whole cloth.
你知道，克雷格曾多次提到过的一点是，其他每个角色多多少少都有原型，泰德是以卡特为原型，马歇尔和莉莉是以克雷格和丽贝卡为原型，而罗宾则是你们凭空想象出来的角色。
And it feels to me like, you create a pilot and you have like, you're like, I hope this costume fits this an actor.
在我看来，这就好比你制作了一部试播集，心里会想，希望这套戏服能合这位演员的身。
But like, as the show went on, especially first season, I could, it almost felt like they were a tailor and they were like, tailoring it to you.
但随着剧集的发展，特别是第一季过后，我甚至觉得你们就像裁缝一样，在为我量身定制。
So they start, this is what I try to explain to people.
所以开始时——这也是我常跟别人解释的。
In network TV and Greg Mailens told me this, like it's really important for the writers to get to know the actors because you start pulling little things from their life and you start kind of giving them to the character.
在电视网电视剧里，格雷格·马隆斯曾对我说过，编剧去了解演员非常重要，因为你会开始从他们的生活中汲取零星的小事，然后把它们赋予给角色。
Now, for me, that got a little annoying slash confusing because I was like, wait, I love books and crossword puzzles.
不过对我来说，这变得有点烦人兼困惑，因为我想，等等，我喜欢书和填字游戏。
And now you're taking that from me and making fun of it.
结果现在你们把这些从我身上拿走，拿来开玩笑。
And now when I do read books or do crossword puzzles, it looks like I'm the character when in fact I started, I predated that, you know?
搞得现在当我真的在读书或玩填字游戏时，别人看起来就像我在扮演那个角色，而事实上我本来就那样，你知道吗？
But I think there's something, could you feel the like snugness of the suit getting more tailored for you in a way that like liberated you to feel like you weren't playing someone's idea of someone, but you were actually inhabiting it more.
但我认为有一种感觉是，你能感觉到那套衣服越来越合身，为你量身定做，某种程度上让你感到一种解放，觉得你不是在演某人脑海中的某个形象，而是真正地融入了其中。
Do you know what I'm saying?
你知道我在说什么吗？
I know what you're saying.
我明白你的意思。
And yeah, I felt that too.
而且是的，我也那种感觉。
And again, for me personally, because comedy was sort of a new area for me to be working in, I felt grateful to it because I thought, you know, they're noticing that this is what I'm good at and they're gonna write towards that.
再者，对我个人而言，因为喜剧对当时的我是个全新的领域，我对此心存感激，因为我想，你知道的，他们注意到了这是我擅长的东西，他们会顺着这个方向去写。
So I'm not gonna have to really like learn on the fly so much.
所以我不用在现场现学现卖太多。
It became much more familiar.
它变得熟悉多了。
And I do get asked that a lot I feel when doing, or certainly maybe back in the day when we were doing more press about the show, it's like, how are you similar to Robin?
而且人们确实经常问我这个问题，当我们在做……或者说肯定是在当年我们为这部剧做更多宣传的时候，人们会问：“你和罗宾有哪些相似之处？”
And I'm like, I don't know, it's kind of blending right now.
而我就会说，我不知道，现在两者的界限有点模糊了。
Like it's a hard now separating the self from the character is becoming more challenging because it's becoming so much more intimate.
现在要把自我和角色分离开变得越来越有挑战性，因为这种联系变得越来越亲密了。
We're all becoming so much more intimate.
我们所有人都变得越来越亲密了。
And, you know, even the storylines have like started becoming, you know, and I think you've talked about that, Craig, about like we were all in this.
而且，你知道的，甚至连故事线都开始变得……而且我想你谈到过这一点，克雷格，关于我们所有人都经历了这些。
And I think Courtney, I've been listening.
我想考特尼，我一直在听。我听了考特尼的那期，也就是我听到考特尼声音的时候。
I listened to Courtney's tooth, which is when I see your Courtney's voice.
我是说，我当时稍微年轻一点，但因为我正处于一段非常严肃的感情中，这段感情在我很小的时候就开始了，我们其实也都在经历着同样的事情。
I mean, I was a little younger, but because I was in this very serious relationship, which started very early in my life, we were all sort of going through the same things too.
所以这不仅仅是编剧强加在我们身上的那些古怪个性和特征，它同样也是我们真实的生活故事。
So it was not just sort of the quirks and the characteristics that the writers were sort of attaching us to, but it was also just the life stories.
它也是如此地引人共鸣。
It was also just so relatable.
所以感觉非常熟悉。
Yeah.
对。
So it just felt very familiar.
所以这感觉非常熟悉。
I think that was huge for the show, because there's always a single like, why did this one work?
我认为这对这部剧来说至关重要，因为大家总是在探究一个单刀直入的问题：为什么这部剧能成功？
There were a lot of shows during and after Friends that tried to be the New York, here's another group of people in New York dating, and it was really hard to get one of those to stick and work and be distinctive and be its own thing.
在《老友记》播出期间及之后，有很多剧集都试图复制那种模式——讲的是纽约的故事，又是一群人在纽约约会，但要让其中某一部脱颖而出、取得成功并具有独特的个性，真的是非常难。
I like to think that some of it was the writing, but I do think that what you guys brought to it.
我愿意相信部分原因在于剧本，但我确实认为你们两个赋予它的东西……
In addition to being unbelievably talented, having so much heart and soul, the two of you having this immediate on-screen chemistry, both of you being so funny and authentic.
除了拥有难以置信的天赋、充满真心与灵魂之外，你们两个有着立竿见影的荧幕化学反应，你们两个都既幽默又真实。
See, it's still there.
看吧，它还在。
It's still there, or there's, of course, I get, I hear this is, this is me and Kobe.
它还在，或者说，当然了，我听到……这就是我和蔻碧。
I blow her kisses and she goes, like she always, she always worked bluer than me.
我隔空飞吻她，然后她就……就像她总是，她总是比我开黄腔开得更厉害。
Kobe's older.
蔻碧比较老成。
Always.
一直都是。
And now commercials, end of commercials, back to show.
现在是广告时间，广告结束，回到节目。
This is what I'm going to say.
这就是我要说的。
And then I have to talk to Josh about something, just to- But you'll be able to listen.
然后我得跟乔斯聊点别的，只是为了——但你还是能听得到的。
But you will be probably reporting and everyone will hear it.
但你可能到时候会爆料，所有人都会听到。
So one thing that I think was really beneficial is we weren't like a crazy hit show.
所以我觉得非常有益的一点是，我们在播出口碑并不算那种疯狂大热的剧。
you know, when we were on the air.
你知道的，当我们在播的时候。
And I've talked to people about this who are fans now who have watched the series like seven times and like, it's such a huge show.
我跟一些现在是粉丝的人聊过这件事，他们把这部剧刷了七遍，觉得这是一部超级大热剧。
And it was like, but when we were doing it.
然后就会觉得，但当我们在拍摄的时候。
It wasn't.
其实并不是。
We were like, are we getting picked up for next season?
我们当时都在想：我们能续订下一季吗？
Like, and it was really like we were right on the bubble and that obviously brought in some anxiety and some stress.
而且感觉我们就像是在生死边缘苦苦挣扎，这显然带来了一些焦虑和压力。
But it also was wonderful because we were kind of allowed do what we wanted to do.
但它同时也非常棒，因为我们某种程度上可以随心所欲地做我们想做的事。
And for us personally, like, I didn't feel like my life changed.
对我们个人而言，我觉得我的生活没有改变。
You know, I feel like if you're the cast of friends or something, it was like, you don't, you, everyone knows who you are, and you're in the middle of production.
你知道的，我觉得如果你是《老友记》的演员阵容之类的话，情况就会变成，你无法……所有人都知道你是谁，而你正身处制作的中心。
And everyone's anticipating episodes, like there, I'm sure that that would be very, a lot of pressure to work under and to create under.
每个人都在翘首以盼新剧集，我敢肯定，在那种环境下工作和创作会承受巨大的压力。
So, I also feel so grateful to that, where it wasn't until like, season seven or eight or nine, certainly building up to this finale, people were writing about us and we were having to do more press and people were coming up and saying, Hi, I love your show and I can't wait for the episode and it wasn't in our world.
所以，我也对此深表感激，直到第七季、第八季或第九季，特别是临近大结局时，大家才开始报道我们，我们不得不做更多的宣传，人们走过来对我说：“嗨，我喜欢你的剧，我等不及看新一集了”，而这在此之前并不存在于我们的世界里。
I remember, I have a story that came to my mind and then sorry, Josh, I'm going to talk about something with you too.
我记得，我脑子里突然浮现出一个故事，然后，抱歉，乔斯，我等下也要和你聊点事。
But when we were in, I think, our last season, and my husband, Taryn, was doing SNL in New York, and our apartment was two blocks from McLarens in New York.
但当我们在拍，我想要么是最后一季的时候，我的丈夫泰伦在纽约做《周六夜生活》，我们在纽约的公寓离麦克拉伦酒吧只有两个街区。
It was on, like, 50.
它大概在……
And midtown.
中城。
Yeah, in the fifties.
对，在五十街附近。
Yeah.
是的。
And, you know, I would fly out whenever I could and, you know, see my husband.
而且，你知道的，我只要一有空就会坐飞机去，你知道的，去看我丈夫。
And it was wild during that time, because I'd be walking down this, you know, going to get a coffee or something.
那段时间真的很疯狂，因为我走在路上，你知道的，去买杯咖啡什么的。
It's my neighborhood.
那是我的街区。
And people would be like coming from the bar and they'd be like, oh, they would have a total freak out because it's just me walking on the street.
人们会从酒吧里出来，然后他们会，哦，他们会完全抓狂，因为那只是我走在街上。
They're like, it's all real and it's mostly people from out of the country, right?
他们会觉得，这一切都是真的，而且大部分都是外国游客，对吧？
And they would just absolutely freak out.
然后他们就会彻底抓狂。
And it was, yeah, they went, oh, this is like, there is, there is like a tourist attraction and happening over here.
然后，是的，他们会觉得，哦，这就像，这里，这里就像发生了一个旅游景点一样。
That happened to me when I would walk by the Empire State Building.
我以前走过帝国大厦的时候也遇到过这种事。
No, I'm kidding.
不，我开玩笑的。
Jordana, my wife pointed out a pretty great geographic loophole that there's no way a Brooklyn resident would be hanging out on a bar on the upper West Side, or on the upper West Side that much, like, no way.
乔丹娜，我妻子指出一个非常棒的地理漏洞：一个布鲁克林居民绝不可能经常在上西区的酒吧闲逛，或者在上西区待那么久，绝对不可能。
But we solved it, right?
但我们解决了，对吧？
Didn't we say, Craig, that her studio was in the West 60s?
我们不是说过吗，克雷格，她的工作室在西60街区？
Her studio's in the West 60s.
她的工作室在西60街区。
A lot of TV news is in the West 60s or thereabouts.
很多电视新闻都在西60街区或附近。
We decided that was the way we decided to sort of retcon like fix it now in 2025 and explain it.
我们决定这就是我们决定进行的一种“事后设定”——现在在2025年把它修复并解释清楚。
Not, I don't think we ever said that in the show, but that works, let's just go with it.
不，我觉得我们在节目里从来没说过这个，但行得通，我们就这么定吧。
Oh, it would be brutal.
哦，那可就太残酷了。
No, she'd just have to sleep in the box.
不，她只需要睡在盒子里。
I mean, she would have to, she's up at 3.30.
我是说，她必须这样，她3点半就得起床。
I did want to say one thing, and then Kobe, you and I can have her private conversation, but I totally agree with you that the first couple seasons, I think we went on Netflix, was it season four, correct?
我确实想说一件事，然后科比，你和我可以进行你们的私人对话，但我完全同意你的看法，前几季，我想我们是在Netflix上线的，是第四季对吧？
I think four or five, I forget.
我想是第四季或第五季，我忘了。
It would maybe between some of their, some of their.
可能在他们的一些……一些之间。
So yeah, that I remember tipped things into us getting a bigger like real time audience.
所以，是的，我记得那推动我们获得了更多实时观众。
But I do think that there was something very special about those first early seasons where we were just like, we felt like an indie band or like, like we knew we had a crowd, we knew we had, we could sell out like a 500 seat, you know, venue, but we were not playing stadiums, you know.
但我确实认为，那最初的几季有非常特别的地方，当时我们只是觉得，我们就像一支独立乐队，或者说，就像我们知道我们有一群观众，我们知道我们可以卖光比如500个座位的场馆，你知道的，但我们不是在体育场演出。
The difference between those early seasons and like ninth season comic-con, which was It's like kind of an insane moment.
那些早期剧季与第九季漫展之间的差距，那简直是一个疯狂的时刻。
I remember a feeling how big the show had gotten, but I think it really allowed us to make this really weird singular show and let us, comedies really need, like one thing I'm noticing as I'm watching, the heart was always there and the characters were always there, but the show keeps getting funnier and funnier because you figure out how to commodify each character in a different way.
我记得曾感受到这部剧变得有多大，但我认为这确实让我们能够制作出这部非常诡异、独一无二的剧，并让我们——喜剧确实需要，我注意到的一点是，当我在观看时，核心一直都在，角色也一直都在，但这部剧变得越来越搞笑，因为你弄清楚了如何以不同的方式将每个角色商业化/发挥其最大价值。
So I feel like we were allowed in the midst of this big Hollywood production, like we were allowed to grow.
所以我觉得在好莱坞这个大制作的中间，我们被允许成长。
And we were also, it allowed us to not become jerks because we didn't have to, we weren't super well defended.
而且我们也是，这让我们没有变得傲慢，因为我们不需要，我们没有极力去防御。
We were just like, we had a really great job in Hollywood and it was really, it was a kick, it was fun.
我们只是觉得，我们在好莱坞有一份非常棒的工作，这真的很刺激，很有趣。
But again, it was like, it was a season to season proposition at the beginning.
但话又说回来，一开始这就像是一季一签的事情。
And we were all the same, I was gonna say this before, we were all the same age basically.
而且我们都一样，我刚才就想说这个，我们基本上都是同龄人。
Like Kobe was like the baby by like a few years, we're all in our 20s and into our early 30s and we're all kind of the same age.
科比比我们小几岁，就像个小弟弟，我们都二十多岁到三十岁出头，我们其实都差不多大。
None of us had, none of us were old sitcom hacks, right?
我们谁也没有，我们谁也不是老派的处境喜剧老手，对吧？
None of us had had all our years and all these carbonite never run at TV.
我们谁也没有经历过那些年，也没有经历过那些流水线式的电视制作。
Should we never even really been on staff on like a proper like multi-camera sitcom situation?
我们甚至从来没有真正担任过像样的多机位处境喜剧的编剧工作人员？
We had, you were totally new to it, Kobe.
我们有，你对这一切完全陌生，科比。
And Josh, same for you.
乔什，你也是一样。
You were, you had done comedy, but you hadn't been on a show like this.
你做过喜剧，但你没有拍过这样的节目。
I think it mattered.
我认为这很重要。
I think it made it a weird little indie band.
我认为它让它成为了一支奇怪的小型独立乐队。
Nobody came in quite knowing how to do the job.
没有人一开始就知道该怎么做这份工作。
So we figured out how to do it for ourselves.
所以我们自己摸索出了怎么做。
You figured out who Robin was.
你摸索出了罗宾是谁。
We figured out how to write for you as Robin.
我们摸索出了如何为你写罗宾这个角色。
And we all got so comfortable together, creating those characters together, and to watch how comfortable you got with comedy, and how much we knew how to write for your voice.
我们所有人都配合得如此默契，一起塑造了这些角色，看着你对喜剧越来越得心应手，看着我们多么清楚如何为你的声音进行创作。
And you too, Josh, like, what a gift to have the time and space to do that.
还有你，乔什，能够拥有时间和空间去做这件事，是多么棒的礼物啊。
What a gift.
多好的礼物啊。
It doesn't happen now, that is often in the same way.
现在不会发生了，通常不会以同样的方式发生。
It doesn't, we really got lucky.
确实不会，我们真的是太幸运了。
You know, we, speaking personally, it was so wonderful to have, you know, Allie on the show to have, to have Josh, to have Neil, to have Jason, who are all like, have such uniquely different comedic voices.
你知道，就我个人而言，能请到阿莉、乔什、尼尔和杰森上节目真的太棒了，他们每个人都有如此独特的喜剧风格。
And I remember there's a few times and be like, how do I name this show?
我还记得有好几次我都想：我该怎么给这个节目命名？
How do I, am I doing this right?
我该怎么做？我这样对吗？
And it was just such a wonderfully supportive group.
这是一个多么令人感到支持的温馨团队啊。
Yeah.
对啊。
One thing, Kobe, we were laughing about with Courtney, which you probably heard us singing your praises, I didn't absorb it, you know, I hear my name and I black out, it happens all the time.
科比，有一件事我们跟考特尼聊得很开心，你可能也听到我们在夸奖你了，我没听进去，你知道的，一听到自己的名字我就大脑一片空白，这经常发生。
There was something so funny immediately about your owning of the newscaster voice, like you were able to really, what went into that, like did you look at local news people and kind of try to mimic that weird cadence?
你对新闻主播腔的驾驭立刻就有一种非常搞笑的感觉，你是怎么做到的？比如你研究过地方新闻主播，然后试图模仿那种奇怪的语调吗？
I'm sure I did.
我肯定这么做过。
I think it was just the energy of trying to be serious.
我觉得这只是一种试图表现得严肃的能量。
Right.
对的。
And I don't know vocally.
而且我不知道在声音上。
And so aspirational.
太有抱负了。
So you're going to be Barbara Walters any day.
所以你随时准备成为芭芭拉·沃尔特斯。
Just so upper trajectory.
简直是青云直上。
Yeah.
对。
And all of it's important.
而且所有这些都很重要。
Yeah.
对。
Everything is important when the camera is rolling.
当摄像机在拍摄时，每件事都很重要。
for Avin Shabatski because she's faced in that.
因为阿文·沙巴茨基（Avin Shabatski）面临着那种情况。
And yeah, I don't remember if I'd like to think I did some research.
是的，我不记得了，我愿意相信自己做了一些研究。
I probably did, but I don't remember choosing anyone specifically to mimic.
我可能做过，但我不记得曾特意模仿过什么特定的人。
I think it was, that was sort of during those first couple segments were more about like don't mess up your lines and have it like as well.
我觉得那是，前几段的内容更多是关于“别念错台词”以及类似的事情。
So I never wanted to take up time.
所以我从来不想占用时间。
I still don't.
我到现在也是这样。
But I never want to like just to soak too much time out of our day.
但我绝不想浪费我们一整天太多的时间。
And so it was more about like just getting it, just doing my doing my good work.
所以重点更多在于搞定它，做好我该做的工作。
But I feel like she didn't you make her?
但我觉得她……你不是把她塑造得很……？
Didn't she become very successful Craig?
她不是变得非常成功吗，克雷格？
Didn't she do it.
她不是做到了吗。
Robin.
罗宾。
Yeah.
对。
She becomes the barber.
她成了芭芭拉。
Very successful.
非常成功。
Yeah.
对。
She's big.
她很有名。
And beyond the end of the series.
而且一直延续到剧集结束。
Yeah.
对。
We don't want to reach right on to do too many spoilers episode episode.
我们不想剧透太多，一集接一集地说。
But yes, she Robin Robin succeeds.
但是是的，罗宾，罗宾成功了。
She started by falling off a horse and look at where look at that shining star.
她一开始是从马背上摔下来，看看她，看看那颗闪耀的星星。
Cause I find you to be such a natural at physical comedy too.
因为我发现你其实也是个肢体喜剧的天才。
And think about more and more we gave you that stuff.
想想看，我们越来越频繁地给你安排那些桥段。
You had to dance as Robin sparkles.
你得扮演罗宾·斯帕克尔斯跳舞。
You had to fall off in the horse poop.
你得摔进马粪里。
We just gave you more and more physical stuff.
我们只是不断给你安排更多肢体动作的戏份。
and you're really such a natural physical comedian.
而你真的是一个非常有天赋的肢体喜剧演员。
Did you know that side of yourself?
你以前知道自己还有这一面吗？
Was that, is that soccer training coming out?
那是……那是足球训练的功劳吗？
Like where did that come from?
就像这到底是从哪来的？
You know, I mean, I did a lot of theater.
你知道，我的意思是，我演过很多戏剧。
I did a lot of, you know, I did a lot of like, you know, again, I was 22.
我演过很多，你知道，我演过很多，你知道，再说一次，我当时22岁。
So I didn't do, I wasn't able to do much before you found me, but I do remember doing high school theater and because I couldn't really sing, which we'll get into maybe.
所以我没演过，在你发现我之前我也没演过什么，但我确实记得演过高中戏剧，因为我其实不会唱歌，我们等会儿可能会聊到这个。
Yes, you can, enough of that.
不，你会唱，别说了。
Enough of, we've been having this argument for 20 years.
别说了，我们为这事已经争了20年了。
Yes, you can say.
不，你会唱。
You give me a whiskey in the recording studio, and you move a couple of movies.
你在录音室里给我来杯威士忌，然后你换几部电影。
We give you a couple of, like- Let's go to the mall.
我们给你来几个，比如——去商场吧。
It's just the pitch here, it's a little pitchy here.
就是这个音高，这里有点走音。
Let's drain that down.
我们把它降下来。
We gave you a green apple, which gets the voice and shape apparently, which I didn't know, and a bunch of whiskey was in in the morning, and then we sang, let's go to the mall.
我们给了你一个青苹果，显然这能让声音和状态变好，我以前并不知道，然后大清早喝了一肚子威士忌，接着我们就唱了，去商场吧。
Could be all pop stars get pitch correction, all pop stars.
可能所有流行歌手都用音高修正，所有流行歌手。
Well, you know- Oh my God.
好吧，你知道的——哦天哪。
So sorry, where were you going about they couldn't sing?
非常抱歉，你刚才说到他们不会唱歌是什么意思？
because I just, yes, you can remember that.
因为我只是，对，你可以记住那个。
Okay, yeah, so just in, I'm great at podcast, I jump around all the time.
好吧，是的，所以就在，我很擅长做播客，我总是跳来跳去的。
I'm so sorry.
真的非常抱歉。
I don't know, we're ruining it.
我不知道，我们把它搞砸了。
I'm just a ping-ponger.
我就是个打乒乓球的。
So I, you know, when I was in high school, we did a lot of musicals, because I feel like that's everybody gets a role.
所以，你知道，我上高中时，我们排练了很多音乐剧，因为我觉得那种剧每个人都能分到一个角色。
You could up like the lead role into four different characters.
你可以把一个主角拆成四个不同的角色。
And they would always be like, we would audition and they'd be like, okay, you just dance from the back.
他们总是会说，我们去试镜，然后他们会说，好吧，你就在后面跳舞就行了。
You know what kind of that kind of moves and so I just had to make my mark I guess at some point as a young actor and so she just tried to shine physically and to dance when I was younger not enough to be good at it but enough to be like you know a five six seven eight moment.
你知道那种动作，所以我作为年轻演员，大概在某个时刻必须留下自己的印记，所以我只是试图在体力上大放异彩，在我年轻的时候跳舞，虽说不上有多好，但至少能让人觉得，你知道，来一段五六七八的齐舞。
I do remember you and you told me this thing that I ended up taking for Happy Thank You more please, but that notion of walk it off.
我确实记得你，你跟我说过一件事，后来我把它用在了《幸福谢谢再接再厉》里，那就是“走开”这个概念。
Like, didn't your soccer teammates, like, when something emotional would have, like, someone got broken up with and you'd say, walk it off?
比如，你的足球队友，每当发生什么情绪上的事，比如有人失恋了，你就会说，走开？
Yeah, we'd say it for physical and emotional things.
对，我们会对身体上和情绪上的事情都这么说。
It worked in the world.
这在球场上很管用。
You get taken out on the pitch.
你在球场上被放倒了。
If you can walk it off, you're going to be fine and the injury will be better.
如果你能走两步缓过来，你就没事了，伤势也会好起来。
And then, you know, walk it off.
然后，你知道，走开。
If someone breaks your heart, just like walk it off and just keep moving.
如果有人伤了你的心，那就走开，继续前进。
Yeah, just walk it off.
对，就当没事发生，走开。
It's actually not terrible.
其实这并不算太糟糕。
It's good advice.
这是个好建议。
Good good life advice, walk it off, yeah.
很好的人生建议，走开，是的。
You could have a best-selling self-help book.
你本来可以写一本畅销的自助书的。
Yeah, I'd find myself saying it to my kids, maybe too often.
对，我发现自己经常对孩子们这么说，也许太频繁了。
Yeah.
对。
So walk it off, walk it off, go, walk it off.
所以，走开，走开，走，走开。
What was your private moment with Josh that we can eavesdrop on?
你和乔希之间有什么我们可以偷听的私密时刻吗？
I feel like we also got away from that.
我觉得我们好像也偏离主题了。
Oh, okay, so one of the fun things I like to do with Josh is there was a lot of sort of, you know, Josh and I had quite a few intimate scenes.
哦，好吧，我喜欢和乔希一起做的一件趣事是，有很多那种，你知道的，我和乔希有过不少亲密戏。
And so I would, you try to, as much as humanly possible, a four sort of, you know, we would roll.
所以我会，在人力允许的范围内，在开拍前尽量。
I would try to whisper something to Josh that was just extremely inappropriate.
我会试图对乔希耳语一些极其不合时宜的话。
And sometimes we have something in acting called the moment before, which is typically used in an audition to get used sort of, you know, you have to land as soon as they hit roll.
有时我们在表演中有一个叫“前情”的概念，通常用在试镜中，让你习惯那种，你知道的，一开机你就得进入状态。
You have to, there's been a whole life.
你必须，前面已经有一整段人生了。
So you have to create this moment before.
所以你必须创造这个前情。
So I felt as a good scene partner, I should lay out what the moment before was.
所以我觉得作为一个优秀的对手演员，我应该把前情摆出来。
And typically it was what we just did, and usually it was sexual- Yeah, because there were a lot of post-coital scenes, yeah.
通常就是我们刚刚做过的事，而且通常是关于性的——对，因为有很多事后戏，对。
There's a lot of like, we just woke up or whatever, we were in bed, you know?
有很多那种，我们刚醒来或者什么的，我们在床上，你知道吗？
And so just as because I am a giving actor, I feel like I'm an amazing scene partner and I'm just thinking about the other person and making sure that they're comfortable, making sure that there's a connection there.
所以，仅仅因为我是一个无私的演员，我觉得我是一个了不起的对手演员，我只想着对方，确保他们感到舒适，确保他们之间有某种联系。
And so I would just sort of set us up before we actually started the scene and our speaking rules, just with like, this is what just transpired between us.
所以我会为我们俩做个铺垫，在我们真正开始这场戏和说台词之前，就用类似于，这就是刚刚发生在我们之间的事情。
And usually, Josh would not be able to say anything and his face would turn that color for those who are watching her.
通常情况下，乔希会说不出话来，他的脸会变成那种颜色，给正在看视频的人说明一下。
Josh is turning the red for those listening at home.
给在家收听的人说明一下，乔希的脸正在变红。
If your listening in space is red, if you're watching, just look at his screen.
如果你在太空中收听，脸是红的，如果你在观看，只要看他的屏幕就行。
Just look at his fucking face.
就看看他那该死的脸。
Well, oh, it's right there to say.
好吧，哦，它就在那里。
Can we get an example?
我们能听个例子吗？
Can we get like a appropriately worded example?
我们能听一个措辞恰当的例子吗？
No, I think it would know you absolutely cannot.
不，我觉得你绝对不能。
We can't get a sanitized example.
我们不能来个净化版的例子吗？
Just think of the worst possible thing and that's really what it was.
想想能有多糟就行了，实际情况就是那样。
Listen, sometimes Neil would do this thing to me, like where he'd have to whisper something.
听着，有时尼尔会对我和我做这种事，比如他得耳语点什么。
And Neil is disgusting.
而且尼尔真恶心。
Like Neil has a real ability to be gross and work blue.
尼尔有一种真正的恶俗和讲荤段子的能力。
He is nothing compared to the depravity that go be smolders laid out.
跟寇碧·史莫德斯展露的堕落相比，他简直不值一提。我从来不知道这件事。
I never knew this.
我从来不知道这个所谓的“前情”。
I never knew this the moment before.
这是我第一次听说这事。
This is for the first time hearing of this.
克雷格，确实是这样，而且她总是掐准时间，在镜头里刚说完“开始”，也就是喊“Action”的那一刻，你知道的，然后我就，我说不出话来，我，我，是的。
Craig, it was, and also she would time it in such a way that she would finish saying, she would stick the landing in camera, say action, you know, and I would just, I couldn't speak, I was, I, I, yeah.
我的意思是，这些都是美好的回忆，但我也，我被寇碧的脑洞给整瘫痪了。
I mean, they're fond memories, but I also was, I was immobilized by Kobe's visionary.
我是说，她，寇碧你完全可以把这个商业化，如果演艺生涯停滞了，你知道我在说什么吗？
It just, I mean, she would, you could monetize this in some way Kobe, like if acting stops, you know what I'm saying?
我觉得你可以写一些最重口味的言情小说。
I think you could write just the filthiest romance novels.
我觉得这是一本分为两册的自助书。
I think there's a two part self-help book.
对，第一本自助书叫《走开》，接着后面跟着一本重口味的书。
Yeah, you write the self-help book is walk it off and then there's a filth book that follows that up.
我跟你说，你在编织最污的叙事网络方面真的很有天赋，我从来没见过，这对我来说总是很震撼。
I'm telling you, you have a real talent for spinning the dirtiest webs of narrative that I've ever, it was always shocking to me.
以它自己的方式令人愉悦。
Delightful in its own way.
这些是精心详细描绘的，比如浪漫的，像言情小说那样的小说类型，比如，这是通往这一刻的步骤。
Were these like elaborately detailed, like romantic, like a romance novel type of like, here's the, here's the steps that led up to this moment.
我们只是让你知道，但这只是我和乔希之间的事。
We just let you know, but this is between Josh and I.
你知道我的意思吗？
You know what I mean?
这是一个特定的时刻，只有我和乔希确切知道在当时的情境下说的是什么，以及它是如何表达的。
This is a moment in time, and only Josh and I know exactly what was said in the context of what was said and how it was delivered.
但现在你知道发生了什么。
But now you know what was happening.
你的想象力可以自由驰骋了。
Your imagination is free to wander.
当他在床醒来的时候，任何时候，或者你知道的。
As he was waking up in bed at any time, or you know.
我完全不知道。
I had no idea.
原来那是……
That's what...
我们坐在那边，在视频监视器那边50英尺外，完全不知道发生了什么。
We're sitting over there and 50 feet over there in the video village having no idea what's going on.
你声音太小了，我们在里面根本听不见。
You said so quietly, we couldn't hear it in here.
这太棒了。
This is the best.
我们在这里为《老爸老妈浪漫史》的粉丝爆出大新闻了。
We're breaking news here for how I met your mother fans.
我们正在打破新闻头条。
We are breaking news headlines.
这就是他们想知道的东西。
This is the stuff they want to know.
我觉得这是吸睛头条。
I think headlines spinning headlines.
而且我也极其容易破防。
And I'm also incredibly breakable.
比如我不是，我很经不起逗。
Like I'm not, I'm easy to break.
但我想可能在一些花絮里，你看到我笑的时候，大概就是在对某种事情做出反应。
But I think probably in some of the blooper reels when you see me laughing is probably in response to something.
很有可能，如果你看到我们在床上。
It might be, if you see us in bed.
现在我看到这个就会明白了。
Now I'll know when I see this.
这就是为什么……
Yeah.
对。
You could lose it.
你可能会笑场。
You could lose it in a blooper.
你可能会在NG花絮里笑场。
It took nothing for me to totally lose it.
我完全笑场简直不费吹灰之力。
Well, it wasn't only that.
嗯，不仅如此。
Sometimes you would get the thing where you needed 12 minutes to recover, like you couldn't pull yourself together.
有时你会遇到那种需要12分钟才能恢复的情况，就好像你根本无法平复心情。
Yeah.
对。
A hundred percent.
百分之百。
And I, and I.
而且我，而且我。
That's the best though.
不过那才是最棒的。
It's such a great feeling.
那感觉真是太棒了。
It's a cycle though, right?
不过这是一个循环，对吧？
Cause it happens and then you're like, don't laugh.
因为事情发生了，然后你会想，别笑。
You're like telling yourself, don't laugh.
你会一直在心里对自己说，别笑。
and then you enter into a phase which you're like, I'm so unprofessional and you're sort of like self-shaming.
然后你会进入这样一个阶段：觉得自己太不专业了，然后开始有点自我羞耻。
Like I'm the youngest one here and they all know what they're doing and I can't not laugh.
就像“我是这里年纪最小的，他们都知道自己在干什么，而我却控制不住自己不笑”。
And Jason would break me real quick.
杰森总能很快把我逗笑。
Like Jason would say, also Jason would always be like kind of singing around me and like, and I'd have to be like, oh, it's so annoying.
比如杰森会说，而且杰森总是喜欢在我身边哼歌之类的，然后我就不得不说，哦，这太烦人了。
You know, it's easy when you're like laugh.
你知道的，当你笑的时候，一切都很顺理成章。
There's something that makes sense that you're laughing about.
你笑总是有原因的。
What was the episode?
那是哪一集？
I think it's in first season, but where Marshall had these pants that Lily wanted him to get rid of.
我想是在第一季里，马歇尔有一条莉莉想让他扔掉的裤子。
And they were like big flowy pattern pants.
那是那种宽大飘逸的有花纹的裤子。
Oh, they were kind of like empty hammer pants, weren't they?
哦，有点像那种宽松的哈伦裤，对吧？
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
对，对，对。
And Jason did a dance through the room, living room going, eh?
然后杰森在客厅里扭着跳了一段舞，一边走一边喊：呃？
Eh?
呃？
So good.
太棒了。
He also broke so much.
他自己也经常笑场。
And that's when it was the hardest, is when he was doing something that broke all of us.
而且那是经历最艰难的时候，就是当他在做某种能把我们所有人逗笑的动作时。
Yeah.
对。
And then he would be anticipating all of his breaking, and then he would laugh.
然后他会预料到自己又要笑场了，于是他自己就先笑了。
I would say Neil had the biggest poker face.
我觉得尼尔的扑克脸最厉害。
Like, Neil would be the, he would the last to break, but he would sometimes break, but he was the last.
尼尔总是那个坚持到最后、最晚笑场的人，虽然他有时也会笑，但他是最后一个。
No, if you made Neil break, you were like, oh, I guess I'm doing something very funny.
不，如果你能把尼尔逗笑，你就会觉得，哦，我猜我刚才做的事一定非常搞笑。
Kobe Josh and I have talked about this though.
科比、乔希和我讨论过这个。
Like, you guys, like some of what you're describing went into the show.
比如，你们刚才描述的一些情景其实都放进了剧集里。
We wouldn't not use those takes.
我们不会剪掉那些镜头。
We would sometimes use those moments because you guys were unafraid of laughing at each other.
我们有时会保留那些时刻，因为你们并不害怕在镜头前互嘲。
And I think it's part of what created that feeling of this is an authentic friend group.
我认为这也是营造出“这是一个真实的朋友圈”这种感觉的原因之一。
I was just texting Josh this last night, I was like, there's something about watching, like we're watching the episode, the duel to talk about that one up next, after you.
我昨晚还给乔希发短信说，看剧的感觉真的很奇妙，比如我们正在看那一集，等下就聊那一集，接着你们的后面。
This is our special Kobe, this is the Kobe episode.
这是我们的特别节目，科比，这是科比专属集。
We're not talking about any specific episodes.
我们不是在聊具体哪一集。
No, no, we wanted to just talk to you, which is the best.
不，不，我们就是想跟你聊聊，这感觉太棒了。
But I was watching that episode and I was like, God, you just buy that these people are friends.
但我看那一集的时候就在想，天哪，你真的会相信这些人是好朋友。
They really seem fond of each other.
他们看起来真的很喜欢彼此。
And I think part of it is the process kind of be gapped that by, we didn't have an audience.
我想部分原因在于我们的制作流程巧妙地避开了这一点——我们没有现场观众。
You weren't putting it on for a big, the friends actors were putting it on for 500 people in bleachers every day, every show.
你们不需要刻意去迎合大众。《老友记》的演员们每天、每场演出都要面对看台上的五百名观众表演。
We weren't.
而我们没有。
And you guys had each other.
你们拥有彼此。
And you guys making each other laugh and the crew laugh.
你们互相逗笑，也把剧组工作人员逗笑。
That's what our laughs were.
那就是我们的笑声来源。
And we left them in the cut.
而且我们把这些都保留在了正片里。
And I don't think, I feel like that's part of what made the show work in a weird way.
我觉得，某种程度上这也是这部剧之所以成功的原因之一。
Yeah, I would agree with that.
对，我非常赞同。
And I think because, again, it creates this intimacy because I remember doing scenes and there were certain crew members laugh that I would listen for, mostly in camera because they were the closest and they were obviously paying attention.
而且我认为，正因为如此，它创造了一种亲密感。我记得在拍戏时，有些工作人员的笑声是我会特别去捕捉的，主要是在摄像机附近的人，因为他们离得最近，而且他们显然一直在关注着。
And you would kind of hear them laugh and then you would kind of lean into that laugh.
你会听到他们的笑声，然后你就会顺着那种笑声继续发挥。
But it was when you're doing a show like Friends and you're doing that, but it's for an audience of people, I think that that energy you're putting out as an actor is bigger because you're like, oh, they're really like this.
但当你拍像《老友记》这样的剧时，你是面对着现场观众在表演，我觉得作为演员你释放出的能量会更大，因为你会觉得，哦，他们真的很吃这一套。
But when you're just doing it for like, just look on Jane, you know, it's a different, they're laughing because they know what you're doing is actually not Robin.
但当你只是为了——就看简的表情，你知道的，这是完全不同的氛围，他们笑是因为他们知道你做的事情其实根本不是罗宾。
They know like what you're doing is kind of a bit of a nod to whatever bit we were doing on set.
他们知道你做的事其实是对我们在片场玩的某个梗的一点致敬。
And that kind of creates a wonderful energy.
这种氛围会产生一种美妙的能量。
I think that we talked about, and I remember we made this decision kind of as a group that we hated when in a comedy, people were saying hilarious things and no one laughs.
我想我们曾讨论过，而且我记得我们作为团队做过这样一个决定：我们讨厌在喜剧里，大家说著极其搞笑的话，却没有人笑。
So we made the decision like, no, if you're trying to make your friends laugh, we should laugh.
所以我们决定：不，如果你在试图逗笑你的朋友，我们就应该笑。
And I'm Sue Fetterman cut in so many reaction shots of people being amused by, and I also think not having the audience, you know, eating candy and amped up, it kept us more like small scale indie film, like, I mean, how I met your mother could get very broad, but it was also like fairly subtle acting for us sitcom, you know?
苏·费特曼（Sue Fetterman）剪辑了大量的反应镜头，展示大家被逗乐的样子。而且我也觉得，没有现场观众（吃着糖果、情绪亢奋），让我们更像是拍小成本独立电影——当然，《老友记》的风格可能会很宽泛，但对我们这部情景喜剧来说，表演其实也相当细腻，对吧？
Two of you, just while we have the two of you together, I just wanna pay you another compliment to make Kobe's skin crawl.
正好你们俩都在，趁着我们把你们两个聚在一起，我想再夸你们一句，让科比浑身起鸡皮疙瘩。
Kobe, you will, so this episode that we're doing right now will sort of be what Alec, I think seven or eight hymnium episodes in or something like that, right?
科比，你看，我们现在正在聊的这一集，大概是阿莱克（Alec），我想大概是《老友记》播到第七集或第八集左右吧，或者差不多？
We were about there, it's about not quite halfway into the season, we just watched and talked about the slutty pumpkin episode, Kobe.
我们大概拍到那里了，差不多快到季中期了。我们刚刚看过并讨论了“万圣节南瓜”那一集，科比。
There's a scene at the end of the slutty pumpkin where Robin has sort of failed to connect with this guy she's dating down in the bar while Ted is up waiting for the slutty pumpkin at the rooftop Halloween party.
在“万圣节南瓜”快结束的时候有一个场景：罗宾在酒吧里和她约会的那个男人沟通失败，而泰德则在屋顶的万圣节派对上苦苦等待那个“南瓜”。
And Robin ends up kind of feeling like the guy leaves her.
最后罗宾觉得那个男人把她甩了。
The guy says, I sense you are not ready to connect on this level and be in a relationship.
那个男人说：“我感觉你还没准备好在心灵深处进行交流并建立恋爱关系。”
And he leaves and sort of leaves her wondering something about herself.
然后他离开了，留下一脸自我怀疑的罗宾。
And if she kind of has this moment where she needs a word of advice about life and she goes and the tables kind of turn she kind of goes to Ted.
接着她迎来了一个时刻，她需要一些关于人生的忠告，于是风水轮流转，她走向了泰德。
She goes, she climbs up to this roof and Ted sitting there having seemed very absurd to be waiting for the slutty pumpkin like Linus and Charlie Brown, but he has this wisdom that she needs in that moment where she comes to Ted and she says, how do you do it, Ted?
她走过去，爬上了这个屋顶，泰德正坐在那儿，苦苦等待那个万圣节南瓜，看起来就像《花生漫画》里的莱纳斯和查理·布朗一样荒谬，但在那个时刻，当罗宾走向泰德并对他说“你是怎么做到的，泰德？”时，他展现出了她所需要的智慧。
How do you sit here and have faith that this person, that love is possible essentially, that this person's gonna show up, this person who represents hope and like, how do you do it?
“你怎么能坐在这里，坚信这个人——坚信爱是可能的，坚信这个代表希望的人会出现，你怎么做到的？”
Is there something broken in me that I can't seem to do it?
“难道我身上有什么地方坏掉了，所以做不到这一点吗？”
Why don't I, why can't I do that?
“为什么我不能？为什么我做不到那样？”
Why can't I feel those things?
“为什么我感受不到那些情绪？”
It's such a great scene between the two of you And such an interesting, I think, you know, that six episodes in or something, where Robin goes from being sort of this object, we're talking about like the tantalizing object.
你们俩之间的这场戏太棒了！而且我觉得这是一个非常有趣的转折——在拍了六集左右的时候，罗宾从一个单纯被追求的对象——我们之前讨论过的那个诱人的目标——
This thing Ted is chasing has decided she's gonna be the answer to all his problems.
成了泰德一直在追逐、并决定让她来解决自己所有问题的人。
And Robin, we've, you and we figured out how to dimensionalize Robin between the pilot and six episodes in, enough that already we're kind of peeling back the onion a little bit and going like, what is going on underneath for Robin?
而罗宾，你和我们一起在试播集到第六集之间，成功让罗宾变得丰满立体起来，以至于仅仅播到了这个阶段，我们就已经开始像剥洋葱一样，去探究罗宾内心的真实想法了。
Who is she really?
她究竟是一个什么样的人？
Talk about that moment or just a moment in general where you started to discover like in that episode, I just was noting Robin is being shown as a flawed dimensional human being, not the object of what Ted's chasing or projecting on her.
聊聊那个时刻，或者整体上你开始发现——比如在那一集中，我注意到罗宾展现出了有缺陷但立体的真实人格，而不是泰德追逐的目标或投射的对象。
She's her own character.
她有她自己的性格。
I thought you played that vulnerability so well, and that was sort of the first moment that that happened.
我觉得你把那种脆弱感演绎得太棒了，那可以说是这种转变发生的第一个瞬间。
Do you remember that scene or that feeling like you were digging into this character a little more?
你还记得那个场景吗？或者那种深入挖掘这个角色的感觉？
I remember that scene a little bit, to be completely honest.
说实话，我对那个场景只有一点点记忆了。
I haven't re-watched the show.
我没有重温过这部剧。
The last time I've seen every episode.
我最后一次看每一集是很久以前了。
There's a podcast that you can re-watch along with if you want to find it.
如果你想重温的话，有一个播客可以边看边听。
It's called How We Made Your Mother.
它叫《我们是如何创造你母亲的》（How We Made Your Mother）。
Okay, great.
好的，太棒了。
But I just find it anywhere that you get podcasts.
但我只是在任何能收听播客的地方都能找到它。
Is that right anywhere you get your podcasts?
真的是在任何能收听播客的地方吗？
You get your podcasts.
只要能听播客的地方都有。
You can just tell them I'll send you the link.
你跟他们说一声，我把链接发给你。
You can subscribe probably.
你大概可以订阅。
It works like every other podcast.
它和其他播客一样。
There's really no.
真的没什么特别的。
Okay.
好吧。
Yeah.
对。
Just like every other one.
就像其他所有事情一样。
Um, yeah.
嗯，对。
I mean, I remember that sort of push and pull of Robin at the beginning of the season because, you know, she's, she's coming out of thing and she wants to be single and she's in this new city and she's very career-driven, you know?
我的意思是，我记得在第一季刚开始时，罗宾身上那种推拉的感觉，因为你知道的，她刚经历了一些事，她想单身，身处一个新城市，而且非常注重事业，你知道的？
And I think it's like it's a battle between the head and the heart, you know?
我觉得这就好比是理智与情感之间的较量，你知道吗？
She's going, you know, obviously I want this career and that requires me to be selfish and that requires me to not really have emotional availability to people because I'm just, you know, this is my goal.
她在想，你知道的，很显然我想要这份事业，而这就需要我自私一点，需要我在某种程度上对别人没有过多的情感投入，因为我满脑子想的都是，这就是我的目标。
But I think she meets Ted and he is just such a catch.
但我觉得她遇到了泰德，而他简直太完美了。
And she's asking herself, why am I pushing this away?
她在问自己，我为什么要推开这一切？
Why am I having a hard time being intimate?
为什么我对亲密关系感到这么难？
And I don't think that she has really thought about that.
我觉得她以前并没有真正思考过这个问题。
I mean, if we think about how she grew up and sort of we get into that and further seasons the kind of father she had and you know, not to get to.
我是说，如果我们回想她的成长经历，并且在接下来的几季中慢慢深入了解她经历过的父亲类型，你知道的，虽然不是说要……
And we didn't know all of that at those early moments.
而且我们在刚开始的时候并不了解所有这些。
And we were still found a way to play it.
我们还是找到了方法来演绎。
And then we kind of, we figured it out retroactively because of how you played it.
然后我们差不多是根据你的表演，事后才把这些给琢磨透的。
I think.
我觉得是这样。
Yeah.
对。
And I also want to just talk about Josh for a bit, which is like Josh is so emotionally intelligent.
而且我还想聊聊乔希，就是乔希在情感上真的非常成熟。
He's obviously intelligent, but there is a depth to Josh as a human.
他显然很聪明，但作为一个真正的人，乔希身上有一种深邃感。
And he is so, he's so ready to listen and just gives the most wonderful advice.
他非常、非常愿意倾听，总能给出最棒的建议。
And I feel like even when we first met, if we want to go back to that time specifically, you know, she's a 22-year-old girl who's like, you know, and it was so wonderful to be able to partner with somebody who I could talk to about life stuff and also have such a depth of knowledge about the emotional, about humans in general, about relationships.
我觉得即使在我们刚见面的时候，如果我们特别回到那个时期，你知道的，她当时只是个22岁的女孩，就那种，而且能和这样一个人搭档真的很棒，我可以跟他聊生活中的事，同时他对情感、对整个人类、对人际关系又有如此深厚的认知。
And I think that that was probably what was happening in that scene at that time.
我想那大概就是那个场景中正在发生的事情。
First off, the Cubs, that was so lovely.
首先，小熊队，那真是太美妙了。
Thanks.
谢谢。
I'm so moved by that, but I also, I think I was 29 when we did the pilot.
我对此非常感动，不过我也觉得，我们拍试播集时我大概29岁。
Maybe you were like 23 and I was 30 by the time we were actually doing it, or does that sound about right?
也许你当时23岁左右，而我们真正开拍的时候我已经30岁了，或者说大概是这样？
But, you know, it's funny because I was like older than you, but this was also new for me.
不过，你知道的，这挺有意思的，因为我比你年长，但这对当时的我也很新鲜。
I had never been on a big long-running TV show, I had done a bunch of pilots and so we were both in the trenches together and I think one of the ways I sometimes deal with my discomfort is I try to like be advicey and sage like and you know but you were I think we were figuring this thing out together and I have such a strong memory of seeing the first you've been the first time like walking down the hall when we were about to test together and I think that, you know, people have always remarked on our chemistry to the point where people insist that I was in love with you.
我从来没演过大型的长寿电视剧，我拍过一堆试播集，所以我们俩当时都在摸着石头过河，而且我觉得我有时面对不适的一种方式，就是假装自己很有建议性、像个智者一样，你知道的，但你——我觉得我们是一起在把这事琢磨明白的，我脑海中有一个特别深刻的记忆，就是第一次看到你、第一次当我们准备一起去试镜时走在走廊上，我觉得，你知道的，人们总是对我们的化学反应赞不绝口，甚至有人坚信我当时爱上了你。
And I think you know that that was not true, but I did always feel like you and I had like, I don't know like we met on the first day of basic training or something.
我想你知道那并不是真的，但我确实总觉得你和我之间有种，我不知道，就像我们在新兵训练营的第一天相遇一样。
Like I felt like we were in the military together and we went through like this life changer together, like side by side.
我感觉我们就好像一起参了军，并肩经历了一场彻底改变人生的大事。
And I, you know, sometimes people would ask about chemistry, did you ever discuss chemistry?
而且，你知道的，有时人们会问及化学反应的事，你们讨论过化学反应吗？
And I'd be like, God, no.
我就会说，天哪，没有。
Like I don't, that would be the worst thing you could ever do.
我觉得，那绝对是你能做的最糟糕的事情。
Like I just had a sense that scenes with you and I were gonna be really honest and they were gonna be really thoughtful and we were gonna listen really well together.
我只是有一种直觉，我和你的对手戏会非常真诚，会非常深思熟虑，而且我们两个会配合得非常默契，懂得如何倾听彼此。
And I also thought, you know, Jordana made this point about your character, especially in the first season.
而且我还觉得，你知道的，乔丹娜对你的角色提出了这样一个观点，尤其是在第一季中。
There's a psychological term called tantalizing object, which is like the thing that like you really want, but it's just out of reach, and you can't quite have it, and we all have that romantically.
心理学上有一个词叫“诱人客体”，意思就是你特别想要、但又偏偏够不着的东西，你无法真正拥有它，我们在浪漫感情中都会有这种感觉。
And I think one thing that I think is fascinating is you met Taryn right before we started this thing, and you're still with him.
我觉得有一点很迷人，那就是我们在开始拍这部戏之前不久，你遇到了泰伦，而且你们现在还在一起。
So you yourself were not, we didn't have these attachment theory terms when we were doing the show, but like Craig and I have talked that Ted has an anxious attachment wound, And Robin has an avoidant attachment wound.
所以你自己其实并没有——我们在拍这部剧的时候并没有这些依恋理论的概念，但我和克雷格聊过，泰德有焦虑型依恋创伤，而罗宾有回避型依恋创伤。
But in real life, actually, we were reversed because you were in this really serious long-term relationship that you're still in.
但在现实生活中，实际上我们俩正好相反，因为你当时正处于一段非常稳定的长期恋情中，而且直到现在你们还在一块。
And I was actually, as you remember from many of our off-stage talks, really confused about relationships, like how I couldn't stay in them.
而我实际上，正如你从我们的许多幕后交谈中所记得的那样，对人际关系感到非常迷茫，比如我怎么就留不住感情。
I didn't know how long if I wanted to be in them, if I wanted to ever get married, I've worked through all that.
我不知道自己想谈多久的恋爱，不知道自己是否想维系下去，是否想过结婚，这些我都已经克服了。
But I find it fascinating that we were both navigating like love and romance at that time in our lives, but from totally different perspectives than our characters.
但我发现很奇妙的是，我们当时都在探索爱与浪漫，但其视角却与我们的角色截然不同。
But I don't know, there was just something about, when people ask like if we're friends, like with the cast, I say sure, but it's actually family is a better analogy because you don't get to choose your family.
不过我不知道，就是有这样一种感觉，当人们问我们是不是朋友时，比如演员之间，我会说是的，但实际上用“家人”来形容更贴切，因为你没法选择自己的家人。
You're just thrown together.
你们只是被随机凑到了一起。
and you have to kind of make this ecosystem work.
而你必须让这个生态系统正常运转。
And, you know, there were, set was different when you and I had a one-on-one scene than it was five of us at the bar.
而且，你知道的，当你我有一场双人戏时，片场的感觉和我们五个人在酒吧里时是不一样的。
Or you and Neil together, or me and Jason and Ali, like there were so many different configurations that changed the energy of what the day was gonna be like.
或者你和尼尔在一起，或者我和杰森、阿里在一起，有太多不同的组合，它们改变了那一天的活力和氛围。
But I do, you know, in some ways like if it's the Wizard of Oz, like you were the Scarecrow for me, like you were like the first person I met on the journey.
但我的确，你知道的，在某种程度上就像《绿野仙踪》那样，对我来说你就像是稻草人，就像是这段旅程中我遇到的第一个人。
And I just like, I love you very much.
我只是觉得，我非常爱你。
And I just, I just want to say that.
我只想说这些。
Say it, buddy.
说出来吧，伙计。
Oh, are you guys?
哦，你们俩？
I love you both.
我爱你们两个。
It's, what a gift.
这真是，多么棒的恩赐啊。
How lucky were, how lucky were slash are we?
我们有多幸运，过去和现在都有多幸运？
I mean, just.
我是说，简直了。
Oh, lucky.
哦，太幸运了。
We were so lucky.
我们太幸运了。
Like it's so, it's such a, it was such an amazing time.
就像，这真的是一段太棒的时光了。
And just, I miss it.
而且，我很想念它。
Like I don't like, I don't really miss people go like, What do you miss most of the show and of like the people?
就像，我不——当人们问“你最想念这部剧的什么”时，我会说“当然是人啊”。
Like being able to just go in.
就像能够那样随心所欲地去工作。
And I think you've touched upon this in your podcast already, which is like life happened.
我想你在你的播客中也已经提到过这一点，那就是生活一直在发生。
Like people got married, people met their partners, people divorced their partners.
比如有人结婚了，有人遇到了伴侣，有人和伴侣离婚了。
We have people pass away, you know?
我们还有人离世了，你知道吗？
It was like.
就好像是。
Yeah.
对。
And we all went through some shit.
我们都经历了一些破事。
We all went through some journeys and some shit.
我们都经历了一段段心路历程和各种破事。
Yeah.
对。
We really did.
我们真的经历过。
And so it's, it's, that made it in there too.
所以这一切，也都融入其中了。
It's just, it was like a lifetime.
这感觉就像是一整辈子。
And when I even say like, we, and people ask like, how many seasons did you do?
每当我甚至说“我们”的时候，当人们问“你们拍了多少季”？
I was like, we did nine seasons.
我会说，我们拍了九季。
We did nine years.
我们拍了九年。
Like, call it a decade of our life, call it a decade.
把它叫做我们生命中的十年吧，就叫十年。
And we were all living life.
而我们都在好好生活。
The other thing though, I think someone to think about is like, everyone sees 22 to 24 minutes of that week that we spent together.
不过还有一件事，我觉得可以想想，那就是每个人看到的只是我们共同度过的那个星期的22到24分钟。
But how many hours were we together?
但我们到底在一起度过了多少小时？
Like, most of our life was happening not on screen.
我们的大部分生活其实并没有发生在屏幕上。
Like, even on set life.
甚至包括在片场的生活。
And people think like, oh, no, it's the five of you.
人们以为，哦，不，就是你们五个人。
And we try to remind people on the podcast, no, it was 75 of us.
我们试图在播客中提醒大家，不，是我们这75个人。
There were so many people around.
周围有那么多的工作人员。
And so many people you get really close to.
有那么多让你真正亲近的人。
Jen, Turkey didn't even do my makeup, but we're still in touch.
詹，虽然土耳其（昵称）甚至都没给我化过妆，但我们现在还保持着联系。
I just adore her and I gave a toast at her wedding.
我太崇拜她了，我还曾在她的婚礼上致祝酒词。
You really get woven into people's lives in a way that is not, the public's never gonna get how intimate and how sweet a well-functioning set can be.
你真的会以一种外人永远无法理解的方式交织进别人的生活中，公众永远不会明白一个运转良好的剧组可以有多亲密、多温馨。
But they do, I think they don't know it, but they feel it in the show.
但他们确实——我觉得他们虽然说不上来，但能在剧中感受到这一点。
Because it shows up on screen.
因为这在银幕上展现出来了。
That made it into this show.
那种氛围融入了这部剧里。
I don't know that it makes, it's not like that on every creative endeavor, but this one, it just filtered in.
我不知道是不是每个创意工作都是这样的，但对于这部剧，它就是自然而然地渗透进去了。
I just had this sense memory of this feeling of walking down to set, as I'm looking at the two of you loving you and missing you, but guys both.
我刚刚突然有了一种画面记忆，那种走向片场的感觉，当我看着你们俩、爱着你们、想念你们时，但是你们两个。
and like, just this feeling of missing working with you, I mean, walking down the set, knowing I was gonna get to shoot, let's say that scene in the slutty pumpkin, the two of you up on the roof.
那种想念和你们一起工作的感觉，我是说，走在去片场的路上，知道我要去拍戏了，比方说拍“荡妇南瓜”那一集，你们两个在屋顶上的那场戏。
Or that scene at the end of episode two of the Purple Giraffe where Robin sort of is saying, essentially, Kobe, what we started this podcast with, which is, can I be part of your group?
或者第二集《紫色长颈鹿》结尾的那场戏，罗宾差不多在说，本质上说，科比，也就是我们这期播客开始时提到的，我能加入你们的小团体吗？
She's saying, I know I'm not saying I'm gonna date you, but it's too bad because I don't have friends here.
她在说，我知道——我不是说我要跟你约会，但这太糟了，因为我在这里没有朋友。
And there's this wonderful moment where Ted says, come down with us at the bar tonight, you know?
然后有一个非常美妙的时刻，泰德说，今晚跟我们一起去酒吧吧，你知道吗？
It was like, he said, maybe in a couple months, we'll talk and she's like, and Robin's heartbroken for second, she knows it's not gonna happen.
就像他说的那样，也许过几个月，我们再聊，然后她就——罗宾心碎了一秒钟，她知道这不会发生了。
Then he says, or tonight, come down, Drake, with us tonight.
然后他说，或者就今晚，下来吧，今晚跟我们一起。
It's this lovely moment where she's invited into the group and it felt like you being invited into the show.
这是一个美好的时刻，她被邀请加入了这个群体，这就感觉像是你被邀请加入了这部剧。
And just like, knowing I got to go shoot scenes with the two of you, I mean, what a gift is a writer.
而且就，知道我要和你们两个去拍戏，我的意思是，对一个编剧来说这是多么棒的礼物。
I know Carter very much felt the same way.
我知道卡特也绝对是这么想的。
It's just like, I get to go shoot a scene with these two today on that roof.
就像是，今天我能在那个屋顶上和这两位拍戏了。
It's going to be fucking great.
这他妈绝对会超棒。
And it's just what is the best writing gets?
这也是最好的剧本能带来的东西吗？
It's the best making something gets is that feeling.
这是创作最棒的地方，就是那种感觉。
So thank you guys.
所以谢谢你们。
What a gift.
真是天赐的礼物。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Thank you, Mark.
谢谢你，马克。
Yeah, we love you.
对啊，我们爱你。
We all, Carter and I, we're just the luckiest writers and all of the writers and the world to bring to you guys.
我们所有人都，卡特和我，我们真的是最幸运的编剧，能把这些带给你们所有人和全世界。
Doings, mutual.
彼此彼此。
Kobe, we adore you.
寇碧，我们太喜欢你了。
We talk about you every week.
我们每周都在谈论你。
Will you come back soon?
你快点再来好吗？
We'll get an episode, a juicy Robin episode.
我们要挑一集，一集精彩的罗宾特辑。
I know I get to come back for the Robin Sparkles one.
我知道罗宾·斯帕克斯那一集我得回来。
I mean, we're going to have a lot.
我的意思是，我们会有很多内容。
We didn't even really touch upon that.
我们甚至都还没怎么聊到那个。
And I'm going to- Who wants you back for that one?
而且我打算——谁想让你为那一集回来啊？
We got to be reunited.
我们得重聚一下。
Yeah, I mean, and he's going to talk some shit about you.
对啊，我的意思是，他还要说你的坏话呢。
He's got some, he says, you're on social media.
他有一些，他说，你在社交媒体上。
And I'd be honest, you know, right there, but he's really difficult to work with.
说实话，你知道的，就当面说，但他真的很难合作。
He was telling us what you were whispering in his ear right before he'd seen the worst guest or I think we had on the show, to be honest.
他跟我们讲了你拍戏前在他耳边低声说了什么，说你是我们节目请过的最糟糕的嘉宾，说实话。
No, that was, no, no, no, no, honestly, thank you guys.
不，那是，不，不，不，不，说真的，谢谢你们。
Thank you guys for starting this podcast because it's so nice to jump into a time in my life where it was just, it was so fun and worked with such amazing people and just revisiting all these memories, you know, of, of times gone by.
谢谢你们创办了这个播客，因为能借此重温我生命中的一段时光真的太美妙了，那时是那么有趣，能和这么棒的人共事，重温所有这些过去的记忆。
It's, it's, it's a wonderful, it's a wonderful journey.
这是一段，这是一段美妙的旅程。
So thank you.
所以谢谢你们。
Yeah.
对。
I actually texted Alec and Craig because I had this revelation that like, we're kind of doing an oral history of how I met your mother.
我其实给亚历克和克雷格发了信息，因为我突然意识到，我们有点像在为《老爸老妈浪漫史》做口述历史。
Like we're going back and we're unearthing these memories and these revelations that we've had.
就像我们回过头去，发掘这些记忆和我们获得的那些感悟。
I mean, one of the things is like, the show is a lot about time and change.
我的意思是，其中一点就是，这部剧很大程度上关于时间和改变。
And when we made the show, we were one way.
当我们制作这部剧时，我们是一种状态。
First season, when we ended the show, we were different, our lives looked different, our everything looked different.
第一季时，当我们结束这部剧时，我们变了，我们的生活变了，我们的一切都变了。
And now, 11 years on from the ending of the show, 20 years on from when we started, things also look a lot different.
现在，距离该剧完结已经11年了，距离我们开始已经20年了，一切也发生了很大的变化。
I mean, it's an astonishing thing to grow with a piece of art and have it change as we change.
我的意思是，能和一件艺术品一起成长，并随着我们的改变而改变，这是一件非常了不起的事情。
And that's what we're doing here.
这也是我们在这里所做的事。
And you, this show is not anything, I mean, it's unimaginable without you.
而你，这部剧如果没有你，就什么都不是，我是说，根本无法想象。
So we want to have you back, we want to keep talking about it, and we both love you.
所以我们想让你回来，我们想继续聊下去，而且我们两个都爱你。
We love you very dearly.
我们非常深爱着你。
We'll do an episode next time, but we needed we needed to just talk to you this time.
我们下次再聊具体某一集，但这次我们需要跟你聊聊。
We just wanted you all to ourselves So thank you for yeah next time.
我们只想独占你一个人，所以谢谢你，对，下次。
We'll talk about an episode.
我们会聊一集的。
Thank you and thank you, Alec and thank you Josh And thank you Craig for having me.
谢谢你，谢谢亚历克，谢谢乔希，谢谢克雷格邀请我。
It's a pleasure to see you and um, and let's do it again Well We've concluded that Kobe Smolters remains as delightful as ever.
很高兴见到你们，嗯，让我们再来一次吧。好吧，我们的出的结论是，寇碧·史莫德斯依然像以往一样讨人喜欢。
There's no there's no dim to her wattage over the years There's no dim.
这些年来，她的光芒一点也没有减弱。
There's no dim.
一点也没减弱。
There's no dimmer.
没有任何黯淡。
It's all brightness.
全都是光芒。
Yeah, enjoy She's the best of the best of the best.
对，尽情享受吧，她真的是好得不能再好了。
What a sweet time that was to be with her and she'll be back on.
和她在一起度过的时光真是太美妙了，她还会再来的。
So thank you, Kobe, for joining us.
所以谢谢科比加入我们。
And, uh...
还有，呃……
You, Kobe.
你，科比。
Craig, we've all, uh...
克雷格，我们都，呃……
We've all had other projects and so am I.
我们都有其他项目，我也是。
I mean, we have.
我是说，确实如此。
You know, here's...
你知道，这里有……
What are you...
你在……
What are you working on lately?
你最近在忙些什么？
Here's the organic thing.
这就是那个自然而然的话题。
I'm going to work into this conversation.
我要把这个聊进对话里。
Let me call a C-block to end our episode.
让我用C段来结束我们的这期节目。
Hey, everyone.
大家好。
If you like Josh and Kobe together.
如果你喜欢乔什和科比搭档。
that you'll have another opportunity besides him and this podcast to see that, hear that is what I should say.
你会除了这个播客之外，还有另一个机会看到、听到——我是说听到——这一点。
I wrote a book.
我写了一本书。
I haven't talked about it yet on the podcast.
我还没在播客里说过这事。
I wrote my debut novel is coming out through Harper Collins, Hanover Square Press on November 4th of this year.
我写的处女作小说将于今年11月4日由哈珀柯林斯旗下的汉诺威广场出版社出版。
It's called That's Not How It Happened.
书名叫《事情不是这样的》。
And it is told from multiple points of view, four different points of view of a family, two parents and two kids that are like a teenager and young adult with Dan Syndrome in his 20s, like 24, and there are these four wonderful characters.
它通过多个视角讲述了一个家庭的故事，四个不同的视角包括两个父母和两个孩子，其中一个是个青少年，另一个是二十多岁（大约24岁）患有唐氏综合症的年轻人，这里面有四个非常棒的角色。
And for the audiobook, we're going to cast four actors to read the four parts.
至于有声书，我们将挑选四位演员来读这四个部分。
And two of those actors, the parent roles, who are named Rob and Paige, will be played by none other in the audiobook by Josh Batner and Kobe Smolders.
而其中两位扮演父母角色（名字叫罗布和佩姬）的演员，在有声书里将由乔什·拉德诺和科比·史姆德斯来扮演。
So there's like, how I met your mother?
所以这就有点像《老爸老妈浪漫史》了？
I thought I was playing the teenager, but it's fine.
我还以为我要演那个青少年呢，不过也行。
I feel, I feel I can do the father and the looks.
我觉得，我觉得我可以演父亲，从外表来看。
I still think I can still play.
我还是觉得我能演。
Take the beard off.
刮掉胡子就行。
You take the beard off.
你把胡子刮了。
Take the beard off.
把胡子刮掉。
You knock the gray out of the temples.
把鬓角染黑。
I am.
我会的。
I think you definitely.
我觉得你绝对可以。
Give me a Jansport.
给我个简斯泊双肩包。
I am ready to go.
我随时准备出发。
A Jansport, a Jansport, a Trapper Keeper.
一个简斯泊，一个简斯泊，一个文件夹。
You're a teenager in the 1980s though.
不过你演的可是20世纪80年代的青少年。
All of a sudden it's a period piece.
突然之间这就成了一部年代剧。
It looks not actually, yeah.
其实也不是，对。
No, this book means the world to me.
不，这本书对我意义重大。
It is my favorite thing I've ever written besides how I met your mother.
这是我写过的除了《老爸老妈浪漫史》之外最喜欢的东西。
And Josh and Kobe have agreed to sort of do a mini how I met your mother reunion in the audio book of my book.
乔什和科比已经同意在我的书的有声版里举办一场迷你的《老爸老妈浪漫史》重聚。
It's called, that's not how it happened.
它叫《事情不是这样的》。
It comes out November 4th, you can pre-order it now.
它将于11月4日发售，你现在就可以预订。
You can pre-order the audio book or the book book.
你可以预订有声书或纸质书。
And I would love it, I mean, the world to me if people listen in this podcast would check it out.
如果收听这个播客的人能去看看，那对我来说将意义非凡。
And pre-orders are very important in the literary world.
在文学界，预订量非常重要。
So if you can smash that pre-order book.
所以如果你能狠狠地点击预订。
This is our most organic two minutes of the podcast.
这是我们播客中最自然的两分钟。
So far, yes, Josh, that's true.
目前为止是的，乔什，确实如此。
Pre-orders are important.
预购很重要。
Go back to your announcer voice, that totally natural announcer voice you were doing.
回到你的播音员腔吧，就是你刚才那种完全自然的播音员腔。
You're like, yeah, it's really nailing wrap.
你就像是在说，对，这真的很切中要害。
No, it is, it's important pre-ordering.
不，确实如此，预购很重要。
It helps boost the book's visibility, wherever you buy books, Amazon, bookshop.org, Barnes & Noble, it just lifts the book and gets it in front of more eyeballs if people pre-order it.
它有助于提升图书的曝光度，无论你在哪里买书，亚马逊、bookshop.org、巴诺书店，这都能推波助澜，如果人们预购的话，能让更多人看到这本书。
So it mean a lot to me.
所以这对意义重大。
I think how much mother fans will really like this book.
我想《老妈》的粉丝们会真的很喜欢这本书。
It jumps around, it's playful and it's storytelling and it's switching off perspectives in a way that I think how much mother fans will like.
它情节跳跃，妙趣横生，充满故事性，并且在不同视角之间切换，我想《老妈》的粉丝一定会很喜欢。
And it's got how in the title, the word title.
而且书名里还有“如何”（How），这个词。
It's got how in the title.
书名里有“如何”。
It's really mean to do that, but everything I read has how in the title.
我这么做其实挺刻意的，但凡是我读过的一切书名里都有“如何”。
And yeah, it means the world to me.
是的，这对我意义重大。
It's inspired by my son.
灵感来源于我的儿子。
There's an element in the book that is about being a family that has a child that has a disability.
书中有一个元素，讲的是一个家庭抚养一个患有残障的孩子。
In this case, Down Syndrome.
在这个故事里，是唐氏综合征。
That's not exactly what my son has.
这和我儿子的实际情况不完全一样。
My son has something different called Jacobson Syndrome.
我儿子得的是一种叫雅各布森综合征的不同病症。
There are some overlaps in those experiences.
这两种经历有一些重叠之处。
And so I just wrote this book inspired by parts of my life, but it's also this work of fiction.
所以我写这本书时，灵感源自生活中的一部分，但它同时也是一部小说。
And it's been the last couple of years of my life.
这是我过去几年的人生写照。
And I am so thrilled that it's getting out into the world in a few short months.
我非常激动，再过短短几个月它就要问世了。
So anyway, I wanted to mention it.
总之，我想提一下这个。
I'm so thrilled for you.
我为你感到由衷的高兴。
And I'm so happy that Kobe and I can help you.
我也很高兴我和科比能帮到你。
I love you guys for doing it.
谢谢你们这么做，我爱你们。
Hey, I have a question, how much did you poll from your own kind of experience with Elliot or how much research did you do into Down Syndrome?
嘿，我有个问题，你从自己照顾埃利奥特的经历中汲取了多少，或者说你对唐氏综合征做了多少研究？
I pulled a lot from my experience with Elliot, but also Elliot has grown up in this wonderful inclusion school since kindergarten that was founded by four moms of kids with Down Syndrome.
我从照顾埃利奥特的经历中汲取了很多，而且埃利奥特从幼儿园起就在一所绝妙的包容性学校长大，这所学校是由四位唐氏综合征患儿的母亲创办的。
And these moms felt like there wasn't, I just write school for their kids.
这些母亲觉得当时没有，我直说吧，没有适合他们孩子的学校。
There wasn't a school that kind of saw and elevated and saw what their kids were capable of.
没有哪所学校能真正看到、重视并发现他们孩子的能力。
And they had bad experiences in trying to find that.
在寻找这样的学校时，她们有过糟糕的经历。
And they said, and this inspired me so much.
然后她们说，这给了我极大的启发。
And this is kind of in the book.
书里也融入了这一点。
They said, let's create a space and a world for our kids.
她们说，让我们为我们的孩子创造一个空间和世界吧。
And one of the characters in my book, the mother in the book, Paige, she does that.
我书中的一个角色，书中的母亲佩姬，她就是这么做的。
She sort of creates an endeavor that can be a place, not a school, but it's a place where her young adult son with Down Syndrome can work, it's this coffee shop, which is also based on some amazing people I know in the Berkshires, I'm gonna give them a shout out that they created this coffee shop for their child with a disability or young adult with a disability, and they create a coffee shop called Extra Specialties that has two locations in the Berkshires, and just getting to know them bit and seeing what they did with that kind of informed one of the character's journeys the mother who literally does that, essentially in my book.
她可以说是开创了一项事业，那不是一所学校，而是一个地方——她患有唐氏综合征的成年儿子可以在那里工作，是一家咖啡馆。这也是以我在伯克希尔认识的一些了不起的人为原型的，我要向他们致敬，他们为自己的残障孩子或患有残障的年轻成年人创办了这家咖啡馆，他们创办了一家名为“特别特产”（Extra Specialties）的咖啡馆，在伯克希尔有两个分店。稍微了解他们一下，看看他们所做的事情，为我书中某个人物的旅程提供了灵感，也就是那位在书中基本上亲历了这一切的母亲。
So yeah, Elliot, my son, the experience of raising him is in the book, but just the osmosis of all of these amazing people.
所以，是的，我儿子埃利奥特的抚养经历融入了书中，同时还有所有这些了不起的人带来的潜移默化的影响。
When you have a child with a disability, at first you feel so alone and you feel so overwhelmed, you don't know how you can possibly do it.
当你拥有一个残障孩子时，起初你会感到无比孤独，不知所措，不知道自己到底该怎么熬过去。
And then you realize one of the answers to that question, how can you possibly get through this and do this and know how to do it is you just get to absorb all of this amazing wisdom and positivity and creativity from all of these other people you meet within the disability community.
然后你会意识到，对于“你究竟怎么才能熬过去、挺过来并找到方法”这个问题，其中一个答案就是：你只需去汲取残障群体中你遇到的所有其他人的惊人智慧、积极心态和创造力。
So I tried to put all of that in the book, the parts that are about Elliot and the parts that are just me being inspired by other people.
所以我试图把所有这些都写进书里，既有关于埃利奥特的部分，也有受其他人启发的部分。
And there's also an element of Hollywood in the book.
书里还有一个好莱坞的元素。
It's the plot of the book is that there's a movie being made about the life story of this family.
书的情节是：有人正在把这个家庭的生活故事拍成电影。
So I have fun with sort of the Hollywood part of my life and I have fun with the disability parenthood part of my life.
所以我把生活中的好莱坞部分写得很有趣，把身为残障儿童父母的部分也写得很有趣。
I sort of bought these two huge worlds that have been essentially my entire adult life and put them together in this book.
我基本上把这两个几乎占据了我整个成年生活的大世界结合在了一起，写进了这本书里。
And it's a comedy, but I hope it's poignant and I'll stop selling it now.
这是一部喜剧，但我希望它感人至深，我不宣传了。
What was the Simpsons where the production came to town?
那是《辛普森一家》里的哪一集，摄制组来到小镇的那集？
And they say like, we're just simple folk from Hollywood and these small town grifters took us for all were worse.
他们说：“我们只是来自好莱坞的单纯乡下人，结果却被这些小镇骗子把我们的钱全骗光了。”
We just wanted to tell a story, a pure story.
“我们只想讲一个故事，一个纯粹的故事。”
Yeah, yeah.
对，对。
Yeah.
对。
I love that about the school.
我很喜欢学校的这一点。
It reminds me of something they say in 12 steps that someone told me that if you're not hearing at a meeting what you need to hear, you have to be the one to share it.
这让我想起他们在戒酒互助会（12步项目）里说的一句话，有人曾告诉我：如果在会上没有听到你想听的话，你就必须成为那个分享它的人。
Right.
没错。
And it's just kind of like, if it doesn't exist and you need it in the world, like make it.
这就好比是，如果它不存在而世界又需要它，那就自己创造它。
Yeah.
对。
Like, that's almost the thing.
就像是那种感觉。
Like, um, there's that quote, is it a Howard Thurman quote, or he says, find out where your your deep hunger and the world, no, where your deep joy and the world's deep hunger meet.
就像，嗯，有句名言，是霍华德·瑟曼（Howard Thurman）的名言吗？他说，找出你内心的饥渴与世界的，不对，是找出你内心的快乐与世界深切的饥渴相契合的地方。
Right.
对吧？
Yes.
对。
没错。
Yes.
完全正确。
Absolutely.
绝对是的。
Like this sounds like a book that you would have loved to have read when Elliot was young.
这听起来像是一本你在埃利奥特小时候会很想读的书。
This is a book I would have loved to have read the day after my son got his diagnosis of having a rare genetic syndrome.
这本书正是我在我儿子被诊断出患有罕见遗传综合征的第二天，做梦都想读到的书。
But I also hope that it's a book that will speak to every family anywhere.
但我也希望它是一本能触动任何地方、每一个家庭的书。
It's really a comedic novel about a family and there happens to be this disability piece in it too.
这其实是一部关于一个家庭的喜剧小说，其中恰好包含了一部分残障元素。
happens to be this piece that there's a movie being made about them.
恰好也有人把他们的故事拍成电影的桥段。
But essentially I, the book, the book will only have been a success if it speaks to every family and every person everywhere.
但本质上，这本书只有在它能触动到世界各地每一个家庭和每一个人的时候，才算真正取得了成功。
So I hope that's what it does.
所以我希望它能做到这一点。
It's all order.
这要求很高。
But that was my goal.
但这就是我的目标。
I'm sure the internet will tell me all the kids.
我相信网友们会把我的缺点全挑出来的。
Can we also plug that we're supporting research from Dr. Paul Grossfield?
我们能顺便宣传一下我们在支持保罗·格罗斯菲尔德（Paul Grossfield）医生的研究吗？
Yeah.
可以。
对。
Dr. Paul Grossfeld, he's he is the doctor who specializes in my son's condition, Jacobson syndrome, but he works to help all kids with congenital heart issues and sort of has a subspecialty in my son's sort of branch of having congenital heart issues and other things with this rare syndrome.
保罗·格罗斯菲尔德医生，他是专门研究我儿子病情——雅各布森综合征的医生，但他致力于帮助所有患有先天性心脏病的儿童，并且在治疗我儿子所患的那类罕见综合征引起的先天性心脏病及其他问题方面有着细分专长。
But he's a pediatric cardiologist and we were raising money to support his lab and his research on the podcast.
但他是一位小会儿心脏病专家，我们在播客中筹集资金来支持他的实验室和研究。
You can go to our website, you can go to how, like, tell me the name of it again.
你可以访问我们的网站，你可以去“如何……等下，告诉我节目名字叫什么来着？”
Go to how we made your mother and then on the top, if you click on Make a Difference, you'll find the link there.
访问《我们是怎么认识你老妈的》（How We Made Your Mother），然后在顶部，如果你点击“做出改变”（Make a Difference），你就会在那里找到链接。
You click I guys want to make sure I said the origin make click on make a difference and that would that's a way to support that work So listeners you have your you have your homework pre-order Craig's book book.
你点击——我得确保我没说错，点击“做出改变”，这就是支持这项工作的方式。所以听众朋友们，你们有作业了：预购克雷格的书——
That's not that's not how it happened That's not how it happened.
不是这样的，不是这样的！事情不是这样的！
That's not how it happened by Craig Thomas and also if you're feeling Generous, please go to how we made your mother calm make a difference and donate to Dr. Grossfeld's work He as is a real hero and has been to Craig's family and so many others And, yeah, thank you for listening, tell your friends, join us next week, we're thrilled to be making our way through this show with you, and thanks for joining us, and we'll see you next time.
由克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）著作的《事情不是这样的》（That's Not How It Happened）！另外，如果你手头宽裕，请访问 HowWeMadeYourMother.com 点击“做出改变”，为格罗斯菲尔德医生的研究捐款。他是一位真正的英雄，对克雷格的家庭以及许多其他人来说都是如此。还有，谢谢你们的收听，告诉你的朋友们，下周继续收看我们，我们很高兴能和大家一起看完这部剧，感谢大家的加入，我们下期再见。
I am guilty, please equip me, all sins are forgiven, in New York City.
我有罪，请宽恕我，在纽约市，一切罪孽皆可被原谅。
How We Made Your Mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas.
《我们是怎么认识你老妈的》由乔什·拉德纳（Josh Radner）和克雷格·托马斯（Craig Thomas）主持并担任执行制片人。
The show was produced by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Madica.
本节目由我亚历克·莱夫（Alec Lev）制作，联合制片人是道格·马迪卡（Doug Madica）。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios, and our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是蓝色点工作室（Point of Blue Studios）的亚历克斯·里夫斯（Alex Reeves），我们的数字内容制作人，即Z世代大师，是艾米丽·布伦伯格（Emily Blumberg）。
Artwork by John Morrow.
美工由约翰·莫罗（John Morrow）绘制。
Please follow, rate, and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在苹果播客或你首选的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论本节目。
It really does help the show.
这确实对节目很有帮助。
Our theme song is NYC by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是由乔什·拉德纳亲自创作的《NYC》，附加音乐由克雷格·托马斯和安德鲁·马朱斯基（Andrew Majuski）提供。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢萝拉·肯尼迪（Lola Kennedy）和埃利奥特·康纳斯（Elliot Connors）。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to sign up for our sub-stack mailing list and for links to our social media.
访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 注册我们的 Substack 邮件列表，并获取我们社交媒体的链接。
You can also click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
你也可以点击联系页面给我们发电子邮件或语音留言。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
你们的故事和问题是本节目的重要组成部分。
Want some merch?
想要一些周边吗？
Click on the store link or go to HowYouGetYourMerch.com.
点击商店链接或访问 HowYouGetYourMerch.com。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's Muse Letters on Substack, order Craig Thomas' debut novel at CraigThomasRider.com slash novel, and you could subscribe to my Dead Father's Society, also on Substack.
在 Substack 上订阅乔什·拉德纳的《缪斯通讯》（Muse Letters），在 CraigThomasRider.com/novel 订购克雷格·托马斯的小说处女作，你还可以在 Substack 上订阅我的《死去的父亲协会》（Dead Father's Society）。
To learn about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign to raise money for congenital heart disease research.
了解如何做出改变，这是本节目旨在为先天性心脏病研究筹集资金的长期活动。
Check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
查看我们网站顶部的“创造改变”标签页。
This episode was made possible by the support of Backyard Ventures.
本期节目由 Backyard Ventures 倾力支持制作。
People will, in fact, dance.
人们事实上确实会跳舞。
The real question, it just hit me.
真正的问题，我刚刚才想到。
Am I in love with you or just New York City?
我是爱上了你，还是仅仅爱上了纽约市？